[Musique]
Pierre Connaissa, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh
j'ai passé une longue partie de ma vie
professionnelle
au ministère de la défense. J'ai
enseigné d'abord j'ai un cycle
d'emmerdement de 5 ans. C'estàd tous les
5 ans, j'ai besoin de changer de métier.
Donc j'ai enseigné pendant 5 ans.
Ensuite j'ai passé les NAP. Quand je
suis sorti, j'ai travaillé 5 ans dans
les tribunaux administratifs et ensuite
j'ai passé environ une vingtaine
d'années au ministère de la défense à
faire tout sauf de l'administration.
Ça veut dire du renseignement, de
l'exportation d'armes, de
l'analyse stratégique et cetera. Et puis
ensuite, j'ai dirigé une société
d'intelligence économique pendant une
dizaine d'années
qui s'appelait comment ?
Qui s'appelait CIS, qui était une
société qui marchait bien, qui était qui
avait été créée par un camarade de
promotion.
Et euh la deuxième caractéristique sur
laquelle je voudrais assister, c'est que
je ne suis spécialiste de rien.
C'est-à-dire je vais pas prétendre être
propriétaire d'un morceau de
connaissance qui va être, je sais pas
moi, le haut carabac de 1792 à 1873.
Non, ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
comparaison. Quand on est dans une phase
de mondialisation,
la moindre des choses, c'est
effectivement ne pas considérer que son
sujet est tellement original qu'il faut
rester propriétaire et interdire le
travail des autres. Au contraire, il
faut le relativiser par rapport à ce
qu'on peut savoir de ce qui se passe
ailleurs. Donc, j'ai surtout essayé de
vous le de d'essayer de comparer pour
relativiser à chaque fois la spécificité
malheureusement de chacune des guerres,
de chacun des massacres, de chacune des
horreurs qu'on a pu faire sur la
planète. Ça remonte pas le moral mais
enfin, je pense que ça peut servir en
tout cas ça peut être d'utilité
publique. Voilà pour l'essentiel.
Bon, ça va faire une petite dizaine
d'années que vous venez nous voir que tu
viens nous voir au minimum une fois par
an où tu es réclamé. Tu as même ton
petit surnom dans notre communauté
qui est professeur Stros
de de de H. Mais bon, tu es tu es trop
jeune pour avoir connu cette série H, ça
te parle pas du tout. La série dans un
hôpital, c'était la série hôpital. Ou
ouais, je me souviens. Ouais.
Et donc voilà. Bon, on a décidé de vous
ou de te deux te faire venir aujourd'hui
pour discuter géopolitique, massacre,
conflit Palestine, Gaza, Israël. Bon, il
y a plein de mots. La première question
que je vais te poser, c'est comment tu
fais pour t'informer quand il y a un
massacre de quelques type que ce soit,
de quelque troup que ce soit, de quelque
pays que ce soit. Comment tu te tu fais
pour t'informer sur ce qui se passe pour
faire attention à éviter de tomber dans
une propagande dans un camp ou dans
l'autre pour avoir accès ?
J'ai pas la prétention si tu veux de
connaître obligatoirement l'objet dans
sa totalité parce que ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est comment l'opinion
publique va percevoir ce qui va être le
massacre. Donc je travaille beaucoup sur
les sources ouvertes, je travaille
beaucoup sur les journaux, je travaille
beaucoup sur ce qui va circuler sur
internet parce que je considère que
au-delà de la connaissance du fait, ce
qui est intéressant, c'est ce que
l'opinion va en conserver. Donc je sais
que c'est pas je ne me prétends pas
spécialiste de tel massacre ou de telle
situation mais par contre la façon dont
telle situation va être perçue ça ça
m'intéresse. Je t'en cite un exemple.
Il y a environ 400 crises à la surface
de la planète. C'est le lot commun. Il y
a environ 10 à 15000 personnes qui
meurent chaque année. La question c'est
comment comment est-ce que tu vas
choisir telle crise plutôt que telle
autre ? Quand je te dis une moyenne.
C'est quoi les sources pour les 10 à
15000 personnes ? que ça me paraît pas
les sources pour le le chiffres de 10 à
15000 personnes.
Bah c'est des chiffres que j'ai vu là
récemment et qui sont que j'aimerais
bien dépioter parce que en période de
tranquillité si tu veux.
Chiffres de qui ?
Pardon ?
Des chiffres de qui ?
Ben justement, j'ai trouvé ça sur
internet et je voudrais bien creuser.
C'est-à-dire en période de où il y a pas
de crise grave, donc pas de conflit
violent si tu veux, on a une espèce de
de ratio de mort par violence qui est de
l'ordre de 10 à 15000. Alors la question
c'est plutôt de savoir est-ce que c'est
des faits du trafic de drogue ? Est-ce
que c'est des faits de violence
interethnique, interclanique et cetera ?
Mais ça veut dire que tient ces chiffres
? C'est l'ONU, c'est l'ONU, c'est les
douanes.
Écoute, je sais plus, j'ai plus le la
chose en tête mais ça m'a interpellé de
mesurer la chose comme ça. Donc il faut
encore une fois essayer de la
comprendre. Je te dis aujourd'hui on va
parler du trafic de drogue. On va dire
regardez, il y a eu tel mort à tel
endroit. Il y a eu tant de truc, il y a
des pays qui sont vérôés par la drogue.
On est en train de se demander si la
Belgique est devenue un narcoétat. Donc
tu te rends bien compte que la façon
dont on va mesurer ces morts, c'est
aussi essayer de comprendre pourquoi ils
sont morts. De quoi sont-ils morts ?
Est-ce qu'ils sont morts de quoi
rivalité trafiquant ? Est-ce qu'ils sont
morts de de querell ethnique ? Est-ce
qu'ils sont morts d'assassinat
terroristes ? Tu vois bien que c'est un
agrégat sur lequel il faut se donner le
temps de réfléchir, quoi.
Et donc les sources ouvertes, c'est
comment tu les trouves ? C'est des
sources ouvertes type journaliste ou
c'est des sources ouvertes du de la
concierge de l'immeuble ou c'est les
sources ouvertes du mec qui filme
l'événement ?
Bah les sources ouvertes, c'est
effectivement les sources médiatiques,
ça c'est une chose. D'autre part sur le
ce qui m'a beaucoup intéressé, c'est
surtout la génération la production
d'information sur les chaînes d'info en
continu. Pourquoi j'insiste sur les
chaînes d'info en continu ? Parce que
en gros, on a connu une transformation
qui qui n au moment de la guerre du Kit.
La guerre du Kit, rappelle-toi, c'est la
première guerre post-guerre froide. Donc
effectivement là on va avoir une
coalition de 35 états pour venir sauver
cette grande démocratie qui est le K
contre ce salot ancien moderniste et
Saddam Hussein devenu dictateur comparé
à Hitler d'ailleurs tiens ça le on
parlera des comparaisons pour fabriquer
une image médiatique.
Donc coalition de 35 armées qui viennent
effectivement se préparer avec une
guerre programmée scénarisée. On dit
vous avez 6 mois pour quitter le Kuwait
sinon on attaque. Bon tu Saddam Hussein
ne quitte pas le Kuwait.
plusieurs épisodes extrêmement
intéressants parce que
le
l'opinion publique américaine était pas
très convaincu en se disant c'est des
affaires d'arabes tout ça. Est-ce que ça
vaut la peine d'intervenir et cetera ?
Il faut donc une préparation
psychologique et on a cet épisode que tu
connais c'est-à-dire cette fameuse fille
qui va venir témoigner devant le congrès
en expliquant qu'il y a une maternité
qui a été
cit la fille de qui d'ailleurs ?
Pardon ?
C'était la fille de qui ?
Attends parce que l'histoire il faut la
terminer. qui effectivement elle pleure
devant le Congrès, retransmit la
télévision en direct. Elle explique que
les iraakiens avaient occupé la nurserie
dans laquelle elle travaillait qui
jetait les bbé par terre pour récupérer
les couveuses pour les amener en Irak.
Bon et puis il y a des journalistes
américains qui ont fait remarquer qu'il
connaissaient cette fille et que c'était
en fait la fille de l'ambassadeur du
Kawait à Washington et qu'elle n'avait
jamais été au Kit à ce moment-là et
qu'elle n'avait jamais travaillé comme
infirmière. Donc évidemment, tu vois
l'imposture, c'est-à-dire que tu te
retrouves avec un système où aujourd'hui
même dans les démocraties, fabriquer une
opinion, c'est un phénomène sur lequel
il faut absolument se pencher. Je
reviens pas sur un autre épisode pour
justifier la guerre en Irak hein, qui
était alors là, c'était du pantomine.
C'està dire le mec avec son Coline Pawel
avec sa fiole. Je me suis d'ailleurs
toujours demandé qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
dans la fiole parce que s'il l'avait
laissé tomber devant l'assemblée
générale de l'ONU, tu rigoles. Bon donc
l'explication la plus logique de ça,
c'est une explication interaméricaine.
Pourquoi ? Parce que Colin Powell était
le grand vainqueur de la guerre du
golfe. C'était le grand rival de George
Bouche au présidentiel. Et le mec qui
lui a confié la petite fiole, il lui a
garanti qu'il y avait quelque chose
dedans. Donc tu vois, c'est une
machination interne à l'administration
américaine pour élimer éliminer le
personnage. Bon et le personnage a
reconnu effectivement par la suite qu'il
avait été manipulé. Mais c'est fini le
truc était joué, il avait été filmé
partout. Bon
combien de millions de morts en Irak à
la suite de ça ? Alors on on pense que
de l'offensive américaine,
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que l'offensive
américaine, la méthode militaire
américaine est assez simple et
répétitive, c'est-à-dire comme on a la
supériorité technologique, on va euh
raser les infrastructures, détruire les
alimentations d'eau, détruire les
routes, les ponts et cetera et cetera.
Puis ensuite, une fois que l'armée est
réduite, l'armée
locale est réduite, on va les hommes
vont débarquer à terre. Alors, je me
souviens d'une interview que j'avais
trouvé assez assez originale puisque
journaliste américain interviewant
faisant un radio trottoir à Bagdad en
disant ben maintenant vous avez la
chance vous avez la démocratie. Et
l'autre disait "Ouais mais à l'époque de
Saddam Hussein en avait l'eau,
l'électricité, la sécurité, tu vois,
c'estàdire ce décalage entre
l'utilisation du moyen militaire et par
rapport à l'objectif politique. Mais
c'était considéré comme une grande
victoire." Et donc se passe une
manifestation qui est assez étonnante,
c'est-à-dire dans ce qu'on appelle le
canagon des héros, c'est-à-dire dans la
5e avenue à Broadway.
les les soldats rentrant d'Irak sont
accueillis par 2 millions de personnes.
C'est-à-dire que la défaite du Vietnam
était lavée. Tu vois comment fonctionne
une opinion publique ? C'est ça qui
m'intéresse. Et donc bref, la suite tu
la connais. Non seulement ça va pas
s'arrêter au cè mais les
néoconservateurs et les néovangéliques
américains vont pousser à la suite quoi.
Donc encore une fois c'est ce mécanisme
là qui n'est pas spécifique. La
propagande n'est pas une caractéristique
des dictatures. Simplement elle est plus
maladroite quand c'est les dictatures.
Elle est plus habile quand c'est les
démocraties. Mais je trouve qu'elle le
qu'elle a le même effet pervers quand il
s'agit de légitimer une violence.
Comment tu analyses
le massacre qui a été perpétré en Israël
par le Hamas ?
Je
Question 1,
pardon,
c'est question 1. C'est un crime de
guerre ou pas ? C'est un génocide ou pas
? C'est un pogrome ou pas ? C'est une
exaction de guerre ou pas ? C'est un
crime contre l'humanité ? C'est quoi ?
Alors,
c'est une armée qui vient euh
se percuter contre une autre armée.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Parce que on a vu
des gamins, on a vu des gamins euh se
faire flinguer dans le dos, flinguer
dans la tête.
Depuis le 7 octobre, on a vu des trucs
qu'on avait pas vu depuis Daesh en
Syrie. Euh c'est pas une armée qui fait
ça.
Alors euh le il faut comprendre
plusieurs choses. D'abord, il y a une
judiciarisation de la guerre.
C'est-à-dire qu'effectivement depuis un
certain nombre de guerres notamment le
la Yougoslavie ou même après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, on commence à vouloir
punir les responsables par des voies
juridiques et judiciaires si tu veux.
Progressivement, on va définir
effectivement la notion de crime de
guerre, la notion de génocide quand le
le procès de Nurenberg va servir
justement à poser les bases légitimes de
ce que c'est que le génocide. Mais ceci
est totalement indépendant de ce qui va
se passer ensuite dans le domaine
médiatique parce que aujourd'hui, si tu
veux, tu as l'impression qu'il y a des
génocides partout. Or, le génocide, il a
un contenu très précis. C'est la volonté
d'exterminer un peuple dans sa totalité
avec des méthodes qui, on dire
politiquement identifié. Bon, donc le je
laisse de côté si tu veux le
qualificatif de ce qui s'est passé à
ce que cherche à faire le Hamas. Oui oui
ce que non ce que je la à mon avis hein
mais encore une fois je suis pas un
spécialiste de la question ça a été de
créer un choc tel que ça provoque si tu
veux une contre une réaction qui puisse
être aussi violente que ce qu'elle a
décidé que ce qui a été pratiqué par le
Hamas. Les méthodes sont effroyables
puisque ça a été effectivement de
l'assassinat de gens sans défense. Ça a
été de tirer sur des gosses qui en train
de faire une rêve partie et cetera et
cetera.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que
ça a été ça a été de de d'encercler des
ky boots, de raser tout ce qui est à
l'intérieur du ky boots pendant 4
heures, de ramasser des mecs, de les
sortir et de les flinguer. Euh euh c'est
un petit peu ce que redoutaient certains
gars du des services de renseignement
français avec des islamistes qui
allaient se faire un village paumé dans
la campagne où il tuait tout le monde
et le temps que les les militaires
arrivent, soit les gars étaient déjà
partis, soit ils s'étaient déjà fait
exploser.
Ça ressemble un peu à ça, non ?
Ben, on a effectivement ça. Alors, ça
pose effectivement plusieurs problèmes
et c'est la dimension politique de ce
massacre. Moi, c'est celui c'est ça qui
m'intéresse parce que encore une fois
les massacres, on en a tous un paquet
sur le dos. Tous, tous. Il y a pas une
civilisation qui n'est pas à un moment
ou un autre pratiqué un massacre. pas je
fais souvent la comparaison entre ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en Israël avec ce
qui s'est passé au début de la guerre
d'Algérie, guerre française si vous
voulez parce que on a exactement la même
chose, l'attaque sur des villages et
cetera des des femmes violées ou tuées
des assassinés et cetera et à l'époque
on avait la réaction qu'à Israël
aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire on ne peut pas
parler avec ces gens-là. Il était
c'était le discours officiel français.
ce sont des terroristes et donc on ne
négociera jamais avec le terrorisme.
Première remarque, le terrorisme,
contrairement à ce qui se court dans
tous les médias, ça n'est pas un ennemi,
c'est un mode d'action. Et ça c'est
extrêmement important parce que quand
George Bouche, grand intellectuel devant
l'Éternel décide la guerre globale
contre le terrorisme, il dit exactement
ce que lui prédisent, ce que lui disent
ces néoconservateurs.
Il faut en profiter pour taper sur
n'importe qui, n'importe comment de
façon à constituer, si tu veux, la
sécurité d'Israël. Et là, c'est
absolument prodigieux parce que tout le
monde s'est engouffré là-dedans en
disant "Oui, oui, c'est le terrorisme,
la guerre globale contre le terrorisme."
Mais encore une fois, les résistants
français contre les Allemands étaient
qualifiés de terroristes par les
Allemands. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est la méthode et c'est le
qualificatif qu'il faut pas confondre
avec une cause quels que soient les
moyens de violence qu'elle va utiliser.
Bon, deuxième chose. Deuxième chose, je
crois qu'il y a une dimension proprement
arabe si tu veux dans le dans cette
horreur qu'a commis le Hamas, c'est
qu'il voulait casser les négociations en
cours sur les accords d'Abraham,
c'est-à-dire tout à coup interpeller la
rue arabe contre ses dirigeants en
disant "Regardez, vos dirigeants sont en
train de négocier avec Israël alors que
nous sommes nous sommes nous vivons dans
un getto à ciel ouvert et qu'ils ne font
rien pour nous."
Et donc tu vois effectivement les
réactions dans la rue arabe, ça va
consister à à dire effectivement
notamment dans les pays du golf, il faut
arrêter la la normalisation avec Israël.
Donc c'était un effet si tu veux je
crois indirect et on sait pas où va
s'arrêter la révolte de la rue arabe
parce que effectivement quand il y a eu
ce qu'on appelait l'Irak, c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu effectivement des
manifestations démocratiques dans les
pays arabes, la plupart du temps elles
ont été réduites par la violence. Donc
il y a une espèce de réservoir si tu
veux qui cherche une espèce de nouvelle
cause de mobilisation et je pense que de
ce côté-là le le coût du HAS a de bonnes
chances de réussir.
Le fait de donc les massacres, le fait
de prendre des otages, le fait de
kidnapper les gens, il y a aucune armée
qui fait ça. C'est pas une armée qui
fait ça. C'est-à-dire que si tu veux le
le Hamas met dans la négociation, on
vous rend les otages si vous libérez les
prisonniers palestiniens. Combien il y a
de prisonniers palestiniens ? 4000 en
Israël. Alors tu te dis attends c'est
tous des terroristes. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'est-à-dire qu'il faut
aussi reconnaître dans la revendication
qu'est-ce qu'elle contient. Il est
évident qu'il y a pas 4000 terroristes
dans les prisons israéliennes. Donc ça
veut dire que les motifs pour lesquels
ces types ont été arrêtés n'ont
probablement pas grand-chose à voir avec
un acte de violence. Deuxième remarque
effectivement et on commence seulement à
en parler maintenant. Tu
as visité les prisons israéliennes pour
ça ? Est-ce que tu as visité les prisons
isra ? Non, j'ai pas visité les prision
israélienne, j'ai pas visité. Mais si tu
veux, quand tu as une cause qui réclame
la restitution d'otage contre la
libération et que tu es effrayé par les
chiffres qu'on te donne, tu te dis il y
a quand même quelque chose qu'il faut
essayer de creuser. Deuxième remarque,
tu vois bien qu'aujourd'hui la question
est en train de transiter sur la SJ
Jordanie et tout à coup on fait semblant
de découvrir que des juifs radicaux
continuent à créer des colonies dans le
en 6 Jordanie, que ces juifs radicaux
sont des colonies illégales, qu'elles
sont protégées par l'armée israélienne
avec des routes réservées à l'armée
israélienne. Il y a une carte du monde
diplomatique hein, qui fait ça. En
écartant les les rues euh réservées à
l'armée israélienne. Tu t'aperçois que
la S Jordanie est devenue un archipel,
c'est-à-dire c'est ingouvernable. Donc
tu vois bien que la manière dont tu vas
communiquer pour expliquer ta cause et
encore une fois de la façon dont tu vas
légitimer la violence qui ne l'excuse
pas. Mais ça veut dire que si tu
construis un discours de victimisation
suffisamment consistant, évidemment tu
vas motiver des gens pour passer à
l'acte. Et c'est ça qui qui est
évidemment le cas le plus le plus grave.
Pour le cas de Gaza, bon, il faut savoir
que si tu veux Gaza est enfermé avec un
seul sorti qui est vers l'Égypte, que il
y a 2 millions de personnes sur un
territoire qui est grand comme le
territoire de Bfort. Territoire de
Bfort, il y a 50000 personnes. Gaza, il
y en a 2 millions. Tu vois que il y a
une espèce de surdensité qui fait que tu
peux pas vivre à Gaza sauf s'il y a
l'aide internationale. Bon et donc c'est
un ghetto à ciel ouvert, c'est pas un
tort de le dire. Évidemment, le terme de
geto renvoie autre chose.
Moi, j'ai choqué dans une discussion à
la télé en disant "Mais écoutez, le
ghetto, l'histoire juive vous apprend ce
que c'est puisque quand les Allemands
fait le ghetto de Varsovie, qu'ils ont
privé les gens de nourriture, que les
gens étaient obligés de de ramasser des
cadavres, de ramasser des rats et
cetera, ils ont fini par se révolter et
ils ont préféré se sacrifier." C'estàd
qu'ils sont morts en se révoltant. Donc,
un ghetto génère automatiquement de la
violence. Si on peut pas continuellement
taper sur les gens en pensant qu'ils
vont finir par qu'ils vont supporter.
D'autant que les pour en terminer
là-dessus, aucun des pays arabes ne veut
accueillir les Palestiniens. Le pire de
cette situation c'est que si tu regardes
combien il y a de Palestiniens par
exemple en Arabie Saoudite où il y a de
l'argent et de l'espace que je sache,
ils sont à peu près 200000 à 300000.
Là où tu pourrais attendre que justement
on disent "On va vider Gaza parce que il
y a de la place, on va les aider et
cetera." Ah non, les mecs ah non non,
vous n'allez pas toucher la cause
palestinienne et sacrée. Donc les mecs,
ils doivent rester dans cet enfer mais
parce que aucun des États arabes ne veut
bien si tu veux contribuer à la
résolution de la dernière remarque et tu
le sais très bien les accords de quand
David deux hommes d'état qui acceptent
de faire la paix Rabine et Arafat ils
sont assassinés chacun par des religions
de leur propre camp. Rabin va être
assassiné par un juif radical et Arafat
par un islamiste. Donc tu vois un peu le
tu vois un peu le yatus, c'est-à-dire
que je crois que même en intelligence
artificielle, on pourrait pas trouver
une une solution à cette crise là. J'ai
j'ai vu un dessin comique dans un
journal où on avait un espèce de robot
qui avait explosé parce qu'on lui avait
demandé de résoudre la
la crise Gaza.
La crise de Gaza.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Tu parles de de
Arafat quand il était hospitalisé à à
Persy.
Euh pourquoi on a sécurisé le l'hôpital
avec
des missiles sol air euh sur la colline
de Medon ?
Alors là, je dois dire que tu m'apprends
une nouvelle. Ça, je t'avoue que je sais
pas du tout. Alors, je sais pas du tout.
D'accord.
Est-ce que on aurait imaginé une attaque
par air sur la salle pétrière ? Je sais
pas avec je sais pas quelle aviation
aurait fait ça.
Pers
pas la salle P
ou pas Per enfin je veux dire je sais
pas je sais pas. C'est ce qui est
intéressant dans ton exemple c'est que
tu vois comment un épisode peut devenir
une légende
parce que tu installes pas un missile un
système de défense solaire n'importe
comment. Il faut le coupler avec un
radar que ce radar il doit
c'est pas c'est pas une légende. C'est
de mes yeux vus.
C'est donné pardon.
C'est de mes yeux vus la source c'est
moi de mes yeux vus
jusqu'au barbelet planté à
l'observatoire de Medon qui coupé en
deux le parc de l'observatoire de Medon
avec radar capable de faire frire des
oiseaux en vol.
Tu veux tu parles de l'esplanade de de
où la partie proprement fond vers
l'orangerie ?
Ouais d'accord. Bah écoute, je sais pas
c'était juste en contrebas. Donc tu mets
pas les missiles solaires là, tu les
mets en haut.
Tu Non mais c'est le point le plus haut
hein.
C'est le point le plus haut.
Non, l'orangerie est en bas. Tu as le
plateau avec le on va discuter chiffon.
L'orangerie est en bas. Je suis d'accord
avec toi. Mais le le dessus de
l'observatoire, la grande le grand parc
c'est c'est au-dessus de l'orangerie.
Oui. Oui, c'est ça. Ouais, c'est ça.
Donc tu mets les missiles là.
Ouais.
Non, non, mais c'est Je sais pas, c'est
possible. Moi, j'ai pas d'information
là-dessus.
J'ai pas d'information là-dessus mais
à l'époque à l'époque les missiles en
question c'est c'était des crotales non
? Comment ça s'appelle les missiles ?
Les crotales c'était courte portée. Oui.
Ça devait être effectivement dans un cas
d'attaque je sais pas ce qui crédiait.
C'est vrai que quand tu penses au 11
septembre finalement c'était la solution
la plus simple
se servir d'un avion d'une ligne
régulière
en évidemment prenant à contrepied les
systèmes de sécurité qui étaient encore
assez légers. à l'époque, on avait eu
des détournements d'avion et cetera,
mais enfin grosso modo, à part passer la
valise comme ça dans le la machine à
rayon X,
les or le truc était d'une simplicité
absolue puisque finalement c'était
trois avions sur le système qui était le
moins défendu du monde et qui était le
plus évident et le plus symbolique,
c'était quand même les Twin Tower.
Et ah oui, mais parce que les avions il
y en avait pas quatre. Non, il y a le
vol.
Moi, il y en a un qui sait dont on sait
jamais ce qui est devenu effectivement.
Il y en a eu trois donc qui sont partis
ou deux ou trois je sais plus sur les
Twin Tower. Il y a eu celui sur le
Pentagone et puis il y en a un autre qui
s'est cassé la gueule, je sais pas où à
l'extérieur. Mais enfin si tu veux ce
que je veux dire c'est que la novation
stratégique c'était de penser exactement
comme le Hamas aujourd'hui que
finalement dans un système qui se croit
suffisamment solide et suffisamment
consistant et suffisamment informé, il y
a un moment où la la
garde se baisse. Rappelle-toi la guerre
de 73, c'était la guerre du kipour. Les
mecs étaient tous rentrés à la maison
parce que c'était la fête du quiour.
C'est le moment qu'on choisit les
Égyptiens avec l'aide des soviétiques
pour dire c'est le bon moment. Donc tu
vois euh il y a toute une mythologie sur
le fait qu'il y a des systèmes qu'on
croit parfaits et ca. Non, il y en a
aucun. Simplement c'est après l'audit de
la des faiblesses de ce système que se
crée le le comment dire l'initiative
stratégique. Quand les Français disaient
les Allemands passeront jamais par les
Arbaes, je sais pas qui a inventé cette
connerie mais ils nous l'ont fait le
coup de fois. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? C'estàdire, tu te dis, il y a des
systèmes qui se refusent à
l'inimaginable
parce que on est assuré de la sécurité
de ces système parce qu'on pense qu'on a
les meilleurs réseaux du monde et
cetera. Mais effectivement, il semble
qu'il y ait des services probablement
français qui informaient qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui risquait de se passer.
Mais je crois que je t'avais raconté cet
épisode
après la crise du Rwanda, moi j'avais
tellement été choqué par le fait que le
la France-Afrique n'avait pas tenu
compte de ce que du risque que ça
représentait. On avait fait avec mes
collaborateurs
un travail avec une question, c'était
est-ce qu'il y avait les moyens de
savoir ce qui était en train de se
préparer ?
Et on avait donc repris toutes les notes
des renseign de officielles,
c'est-à-dire notes du télégramme
diplomatique du quedé, note de
renseignement de la DGSE, note de la
direction du renseignement militaire et
cetera pour savoir si des gens installés
ou chargés de surveiller ce qui se
passait au Rwanda avaient alerté sur non
pas sur ce qui allait se passer parce
que personne n'aurait imaginé que la
l'horreur serait serait pareil mais
qu'il y avait quelque chose de malsin.
On l'a su après, il y avait des affiches
dans la rue, il fallait exterminer les
cafars, c'est-à-dire les tout et cetera.
Bon, aucune aucun télégramme
diplomatique n'alertait sur ça. On s'est
déjà tous tapé hein avant la crise,
pendant la crise et ensuite les notes de
la direction du renseignement militaire
se préoccupaient surtout de question
militaire, c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui se
passait dans le l'est du Rwanda et
cetera. Il y avait une note de la DGSE
qui alertait qui disait il y a quelque
chose de de malsin qui est en train de
se préparer. Mais quand tu es dans un
système hiérarchisé, tu vois bien qu'au
fur et à mesure que tu montes dans la
hiérarchie, tu as toujours un mec qui
disent "Mais il y a quand même qu'un
seul mec qui dit ça, est-ce que ça vaut
la peine de d'alerter le chef ?" Tu vois
ce que joue ce phénomène ? C'est de la
sociologie des organisations, hein.
Celui qui va se décider à les porter sur
le bureau du chef, on dit il y a quelque
chose de grave, il prend un risque. S'il
se plante, on est sûr qu'on va le
poursuivre toute sa vie pour cette
plantée.
Bon, sur le le massacre du Hamas,
oui,
il y a pas des services de renseignement
qui traînent dans le coin. que ce soit
israélien, que ce soit égyptien, que ce
soit turc, que ce soit américain, je
pense que l'intégralité des
communications de Gaza doiv être spoté
par la NSA
avec toute l'intelligence artificielle
qui va bien derrière pour reconnaître
qui est qui. Il y a eu un dra
technologique local.
Il y a eu il y a eu quoi là ? Pourquoi
la réaction israélienne a pris autant de
temps ? Pourquoi ? Il y a eu une
dissémination des forces
pas opérationnelle, pas productive pour
défendre
je je vais reparler des pauvres gamins.
Nous, on a eu accès à des vidéos de de
ce qui s'est passé là-bas. Alors, c'est
pas les vidéos qui ont été compilées
présentées à des journalistes ou
présenté à des députés, mais depuis le
depuis le 7,
on filtre
la tuerie.
Et et on se pose la question, c'est les
services israéliens, c'est les mêmes
Benet que ils peuvent que que d'autres
de pays occidentaux. C'est des mecs qui
avaient pas envie de déranger le chef.
C'est des mecs
Oui, mais encore une fois, est-ce qu'ils
vont être virés ces mecs là infini ?
J'espère Non,
je sais pas, je sais pas. Je peux pas
dire non. Je crois qu'il faut que tu
mesures le fait que un système de
défense, de sécurité, de renseignement,
il a sa logique.
Il a sa logique. C'est-à-dire le
principe même de la surprise
stratégique, c'est que connaissant ces
systèmes là, tu vas en prendre le
contrepied. Je te reprends l'exemple du
11 septembre. Personne à la CIA, ni l'OF
FBI, ni qui que ce soit n'aurait imaginé
que quatre avions viendraient se jeter
sur des tours ou sur le Pentagone.
Parce qu'encore une fois, c'était un
scénario de l'inimaginable. C'est ce qui
s'est passé avec le Hamas, c'est-à-dire
personne n'aurait pu penser que ce
serait de telles horreurs qui seraient
commises parce que c'est dans l'horreur
que ce geste trouve sa signification. Tu
vois, c'est pas une invasion militaire,
c'est une invasion du massacre. Et cette
invasion du massacre, elle est destinée
justement à provoquer ce choc à la fois
pour que les Israéliens répliquent
brutalement ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire, que tout à coup il y ait cette
audite et surtout que si tu veux on soit
obligé de se poser la question en disant
"Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe à Gaza ?"
Je laisse de côté la question de la rue
arabe qui effectivement est en train de
bouillonner. Donc tu vois que la
surprise stratégique, on se dit toujours
non, c'est pas possible. Mais il y a des
il y a des dizaines d'exemples dans la
tu vois euh par exemple
le
j'ai travaillé sur le lobby saoudien.
Tu te dis un pays comme celui-là, c'est
intéressant parce que sa politique de
communication, c'est qu'on ne parle pas
de l'Arabie Saoudite. Donc c'est très
pratique parce que effectivement, tu
vois, quand il y a le 11 septembre, il y
a 15 Saoudiens sur 19 terroristes, mais
personne ne met en accusation à l'Arabie
Saoudite. On va chercher l'Iran, l'Irak
et la Corée du Nord. Tu imagines la tête
des Nord-Coréens quand ils ont appris
qu'ils étaient la conséquence du 11
septembre quand même. Bon donc tu as des
forces de je pensais de réflexion
stratégique qui sont interne au système
et qui disent "Vous inquiétez pas chef,
on va vous résoudre la question."
J'imagine queutour de Brejnief quand ils
ont décidé l'Afghanistan, il y avait
aussi des mecs qui leur disaient "Vous
savez l'Afghanistan, vous inquiétez pas,
on va vous faire ça vite fait chef.
C'est plié.
C'est plié." Oui, c'est ça. Alors, tu
vois, les les Russes vont y passer 10
ans, les Américains vont y passer 20 ans
avant de se décider à partir. Alors, et
ils avaient déjà gonflé les anglais à
l'époque de l'Empire. Donc, tu te dis
"Mais attendez, mais tu vas pas
expliquer à un chef de la plus grande
nation du monde que vous savez cette
bande de Boujadi, c'est très compliqué.
C'est une zone de confin. Vous pouvez
prendre la capitale chef, il y a pas un
problème. Mais par contre, il faut
prendre les vallées les unes derrière
les autres parce que dans chacune de ces
vallées s'est réfugié une population qui
était persécuté par les empires
environnants. Alors quand tu vas en
Afghanistan et que tu connais que tu
sais que chaque vallée tu dois changer,
tu dois faire le la connaissance du chef
local et cetera, ça veut dire que pour
prendre ce pays, il faut mettre des
millions d'hommes. Bon, tu vois bien que
c'est pas à la dimension de quelque
guerre que ce soit. Donc il faut pas se
convaincre de l'idée qu'il y a des
systèmes qui qui sont parfaits parce que
le principe même de la de l'art
militaire, c'est de prendre l'autre par
surprise. Donc quand tu connais les
règles de l'autre, tu as plus de
facilité à pouvoir le penser. Et tu vois
cette idée que Ben Laden que les
Américains connaissaient puisque il
était l'agent qui passait l'argent
américain au moujidin afghan. Alors à
l'époque, rappelle-toi, c'était pas des
talibans, c'était des boujines, des
combattants. Le qualificatif est
important, hein. Et donc, tu te rends
compte que même ça, c'était sorti des
esprits. Euh ce qui avait excès le
camarade Ben Laden, c'est que
quand donc on va se décider la guerre du
Kouit, bon
le Ben Laden, il dit "Mais moi, j'ai des
combattants, j'ai des combattants qui
ont d'expérience, ils ont combattu en
Afghanistan et cetera. Donc, je peux
défendre la terre des lieux, moi
musulman. Les rois disent "Écoutez mon
ami, on va parler de son gens sérieux,
on va accepter l'offre des Américains."
C'est-à-dire qu'ils vont voir débarquer
sur le pays, la terre des lieux saint,
des mecs avec des femmes qui conduisent,
qui foutent une raclée à la police
religieuse quand on vient leur rappeler
que ils ont pas le droit. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? Et donc le choc que ça a
représenté pour Ben Laden, ça voulait
dire que même la dynastie saoudienne
était une espèce de dynastie de traître.
Bon, il y aura d'ailleurs des attentats
sur le sol saoudien. Mais tu te dis, si
tu ne comprends pas comment l'autre
fonctionne, tu peux prévoir le système
de défense le plus parfait du monde. Il
y aura toujours un interstice et un mode
de raisonnement de l'autre qui peut te
prendre par surprise.
Avant de parler de la réaction de
l'armée israélienne ou du gouvernement
israélien,
tu parles de sémantique, de champ
lexical, de de mots employés.
Quel mot on doit mettre sur qui et
comment ?
Sur quoi ? Sur
le conflit. Le conflit qui a été
déclenché par les singlé du Hamas. C'est
quoi ? C'est une force armée qui réagit
face à une colonalisation
où c'est des terroristes fous de dieu
complètement camé au Captagon.
On les appelle comment alors
le
encore une fois le qualificatif de
terroriste est insuffisant. Il est
insuffisant parce qu'encore une fois on
qualifie la méthode sans se poser la
question de la raison. Bon, deuxième
chose, effectivement dis toujours ce
conflit c'est la conflit de deux
radicalismes l'un face à l'un face à
l'autre et ça ça me paraît absolument
essentiel à comprendre. C'est-à-dire que
Netaniaou a fait tout ce qu'il pouvait
non seulement pour que le Hamas soit
complètement encerclé dans Gaza et
rappelle-toi que le Hamas gagne des
élections contre l'OLP, c'est-à-dire que
bouillonner dans le dans le contre le
Fatar le l'OLP. Alors je me trompe
peut-être.
Oui, enfin contre le la partie si tu
veux de l'autorité palestinienne. Peu
importe. Donc si tu veux, si le Hamas
gagne ses élections, même si après il va
évidemment truquer le truc, garder le
pouvoir et cetera, ça voulait dire que
ça traduisait une espèce de fracture
avec ce qui se négociait avec le
l'autorité palestinienne. Donc il y
avait effectivement euh un risque, mais
ce risque, comment est-ce qu'on prend en
compte ce risque ? C'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'on peut aller jusqu'à imaginer les
horreurs qu'ils vont pratiquer ? Non.
Mais encore une fois, le principe de
l'horreur, c'est que s'il va justement
obliger tout le monde à se positionner
par rapport à ça. Je te reprends le
début de la guerre d'Algérie, je te dis
pareil en France c'était non mais c'est
évident, on ne discutera jamais avec ces
terroristes. Bon donc la méthode
et ben c'est des terroristes c'est c'est
quoi cette c'est quoi de ce massacre ?
C'est du massacre.
Mais c'est du massacre. Pourquoi as-tu
besoin de mettre un qualificatif de
terroriste ? Non, parce que si tu le
clives avec terroriste, tu vas rentrer
dans une problématique où on va dire "Ah
oui, mais le terrorisme c'est c'a." Non,
si c'est massacré des civils, si tu les
bombardes avec des avions, tu crois que
ça fait une différence ? Ça fait une
sacrée différence quand même. Le mec qui
est dans son avion, il balance sa bombe,
il appuie sur un bouton, un mec qui
poursuit des pauvres gamins, qui court,
qui leur tire dans le dos, qui leur tire
dans
Mais tu crois que le mec dans son avion,
il fait la différence avec des bombes
qui vont séparer les femmes et les
enfants ? Enfin, je veux dire, le
massacre, il est le même. Le massacre
est le même. Il faut pas se s'arrêter
sur le fait qu'il y a une manière légale
de faire la guerre. C'est ce que font
les Israéliens actuellement. Donc, tu
vois que finalement, ils vont évidemment
pour préserver leurs hommes multiplier
les bombardements aériens. Je une
parenthèse. C'est légal de faire un
siège total d'une population civile
de faire pardon
un siège total d'une population civile ?
Un siège total.
Non, c'est pas légal. Mais encore une
fois, la guerre n'est pas un droit
légal. La guerre est une aversion d'un
système de valeur et un système
juridique. C'est-à-dire que si tu
décides la guerre, tu as le droit de
tuer et si tu refuses de tuer, tu es tué
par tes compatriotes. Donc déjà, intègre
ça dans ta tête parce que encore une
fois, on est dans un dans un monde où
effectivement l'inversion des valeurs va
justement te permettre notamment des
viols que tu tu as pas le droit de faire
en temps normal. Le principe de du viol,
rappelle-toi que pendant longtemps, le
viol femmes était considéré comme un
dommage collatéral. Ce n'est qu'à partir
de la Yugoslavie qu'on a considéré que
c'était un crime de guerre. Tu vois
cette évolution de la cette évolution de
la de la pensée et de la formalisation
juridique des guerres. Donc euh moi je
continue à penser que si tu veux si tu
que tues des populations en les
bombardant ou que tu tues des
populations en les en les mitraillant,
le résultat est le même. C'est-à-dire
c'est un déchaînement de violence. ce
déchaînement de violence, tu vas le
légitimer à chaque fois par le fait que
tu dis "Mais je suis victime." C'est une
réaction normale. C'est ce que les mecs
du Hamas vont expliquer en expliquant
que c'est la situation est devenue
intolérable et donc que le massacre de
ces populations israéliennes est
légitime. C'est c'est la base même du
salafisme, c'est-à-dire les attentats
qu'on a subi nous sont construits autour
d'une mythologie qui est que les
musulmans sont opprimés, les musulmans
sont massacrés et cetera et cetera et
avec cette idée que la France est est
une cible. Bon, une des raisons pour
laquelle la France est une cible, tu dis
même quand dans des guerres où on a
aucun rapport, on se retrouve une cible.
Je te prends deux exemples récents. Tu
as un Chechen et un Ingouche qui sont
venus chacun assassiner un professeur
d'histoire de en France. Le Tchenen,
il est arrivé, il avait
pardon
paix à son âme.
Oui, enfin c'est surtout Samuel Patti le
pauvre. Ouis. Et donc si tu veux ce
gosse arrive avec le qualificatif TC.
Alors, tu sais, les pauvres sont
massacrés par les Russes et cetera, donc
ils ont droit à droit d'asile. Bon,
c'est la communauté la plus importante
après les Maghrébains chez Daesh quand
même. Enfin, ça c'est pas grave. La
CNDA, la Cour nationale du droit d'asile
n'a pas rien à faire de ce genre de
choses. Euh le le type
chaîn sont pas tous des terroristes,
hein.
Ah bah certaines, non, certaines non.
Mais si tu veux leur accorder le droit
d'asile sans vérifier qu'ils ne sont pas
des violents, c'est quand même un
postul. Alors, je te prop pourquoi je te
dis ça ? Parce que la famille Enzorof
s'était vu refuser le droit d'asile.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les gens de la CNDA
qui sont quand même loin d'être des
idiots, si tu veux, ils en avaient marre
d'entendre le discours qu'il aurait
préparé par les ONG pour convaincre le
type, voilà ce que vous devez dire
devant la Cour nationale du droit
d'asile. Alors quand les types creusent
un peu en disant d'accord, vous étiez
dans quel village alors à quel moment
vous avez été quels ont été les
massacres qui sont passés dans la prier
? À ce moment-là, le type s'écroule et
donc la CNDA se trouve dans cette
situation étrange où elle va avoir un
mec qu'on peut plus renvoyer parce que
évidemment faut à ce moment-là faire une
procédure d'expulsion et cetera. Le mec
va être logé, la famille Enzorof est
logée à à HRE à la cité. Rappelle pour
notre communauté qui était la famille
Anzorov. Alors la famille Anzorov donc
est une famille tchchenen qui va arriver
en France et demander le l'asile qui va
être logé dans un HLM où j'ai moi-même
habité à Évreux la cité de la Madeleine.
Donc tu te dis attends les mecs pourquoi
veux-tu qu'ils partent ?
Et donc le gosse arrive à l'âge de 2
ans, il fait l'école républicaine. Or
après avoir fait l'école républicaine,
il va aller égorger Samuel Pati qu'il ne
connaît pas. Donc première remarque,
c'est dans sa famille qu'il s'est
radicalisé.
Là c'est quand même un problème grave.
Et deuxième chose, évidemment, il
n'était même pas prof de Samuel Patti
puisqu'il va être obligé de se le faire
désigner par des élèves et cetera et il
va le décapiter.
Euh il aurait pu simplement
l'assassiner, non, il le décapite et le
père le félicite. Il félicite son fils.
Alors il a été abattu par la police mais
il félicite son fils et toute la famille
rentre en Tuéchen tu veux que je
recommence l'histoire doucement ou pas ?
Lingouche ? Alors on dit lingouche c'est
pas pareil, c'est pas les chechan.
Ouais, c'est les cousins, c'est pas
grave. Mais tu as maintenant un igouche
qui va venir assassiner un prof d'un
lycée dans lequel il était lui-même
élève et il va prendre un professeur
d'histoire et encore une fois, bon la
scène, on l'a vu filmer effectivement,
on sent qu'il est venu pour tuer
quelqu'un, on sait pas qui, mais enfin
visiblement l'idée qui tue lui aussi un
professeur d'histoire te montre un
espèce de rapport à la connaissance qui
est particulièrement perd perturbante
quand tu es en fa des enseignants qui
vont essayer d'introduire une espèce
d'esprit critique dans les communautés.
Ça déstabilise l'histoire. Si tu te dis
ta communauté a des massacres comme la
communauté des autres ont des massacres,
ça va pas avec la mythologie. Nous, tu
sais bien que c'était Jean d'arc,
Versetorix et cetera. Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? Moi ça m'intéresse beaucoup
en ce moment de faire ce tour sur cette
espèce de retour sur l'histoire parce
que prend le cas de l'URSS, il y avait
une histoire officielle, triomphe du
communisme et cetera et cetera. Première
question maintenant que l'URSS n'existe
plus, le communisme n'existe plus,
comment tuenseignes ce sujet-là 70 ans
d'histoire universelle ? intéressant
comme question. Deuxième question,
chacun des États indépendants est en
train de se construire son discours
national. Son discours national
évidemment avec ses héros, ses massacres
et cetera. Dans des pays comme l'Inde
aujourd'hui, ils sont en train de
réviser les manuels scolaires parce
qu'ils veulent supprimer rien moins que
5 siècles de domination musulmane. Les
Mogoles et cetera. Tu te rends compte un
peu de ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire qu'ils sont en train de manipuler
l'histoire parce que l'histoire est une
est une espèce de science déstabilisante
parce que tu es obligé d'accepter que
l'autre puisse avoir une légitimité, que
l'autre puisse vivre avec toi et cetera
et cetera. Je te mets pas le l'exemple
des bouddhistes parce que là c'est le
plus ridicule l'exemple des bouddhistes.
Moi j'y suis allé au parce que
l'ambassadeur est un copain. Je suis
allé visiter le le mien de mar.
Tu connais l'histoire de ces royengia
les pauvres types ? Ceuxlà ils
n'existent pas. Ils n'existent pas.
musulmans.
Alors, les royong sont des musulmans que
les anglais ont fait venir en Birmanie,
enfin actuellement bien Myanmar, pour
travailler sur les plantations de thé.
Bon, alors évidemment, de ce côté-là, le
cynisme des anglais, tu les connais, ils
sont formidables. Cette population
coûtait moins cher que les bouddhistes.
Bref, quand le pays devient indépendant,
les birmands disent "Mais attendez, ces
gens-là sont pas de chez nous." Donc il
est apatri mais à Patride que le
Bangladesh ne veut pas récupérer
puisqu'ils disent "Mais attendez, ils
sont chez vous, ils sont chez vous, non
? Non, on les récupère pas."
Donc ces gens-là ont été des apatrides
et nés dans un dans le milieu bouddhiste
qui n'est pas celui de Matthicar et du
Dalay Lama. Un mec s'appelle Viratou qui
est un véritable Hitler. Le mec il
explique qu'il faut bouffer du musulman,
il faut tuer du musulman et cetera. Et
donc ces pauvres types qui sont
évidemment l'objet de massacre sont
obligés de se réfugier dans la zone du
delta où ni le Bangladesh ni la
Birmanine veut les récupérer. Ils sont
dans des zones inondables. Vas-tu
trouver un BHL pour les défendre ?
Non, c'est pas une cause médiatique ce
truc là. Écoutez ce type qu'est-ce qui
représente ? Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? Le terme médiatique me paraît
extrêmement important. Pourquoi ?
Ça fait plus ça fait plus de 40 ans que
ça dure. C'est le le
Et ben, tu peux te dire BHL aurait pu
faire un voyage sur place. Non,
écoute, BHL a fait la semaine dernière
une chronique dans le point disant euh
je vous écris d'Israël. Alors, je lui
envoyé un mot en disant est-ce que la
semaine prochaine vous allez parler de
je suis de Gaza ? Non.
Tu vois comment moi c'est cette
fabrication de l'opinion qui m'intéresse
parce que je me dis il y a pas
d'inhumanité spécifique dans certains
endroits. Il y a des situations de
rapport au bourreau, à victime et tu
t'aperçois que tout le monde peut
devenir bourreau à un moment ou un
autre.
La réaction israélienne,
la vengeance,
comment tu qualifies ça ? Le résultat,
quelles vont être les perspectives de ça
? Est-ce que l'arithmétique de la
rébellion va s'appliquer ? Euh
est-ce que est-ce que il fallait euh
mettre la communauté internationale des
forces d'interposition ? Il fallait
faire mettre des observateur ? Il
fallait il fallait faire quoi ? Quand il
y a deux voisins qui vont s'écharper
qu'il y en a un qui prend le fusil.
Les autres voisins quand les autres
voisins regardent, ça se termine mal. Si
les autres voisins se mettent au milieu
pour séparer les les Belgiès, comment ça
se passe ? Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Comment on fait ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
?
Écoute, tu sais le système international
est un système qui avance par coup,
hein. Faut pas s'imaginer que il y a un
mec à New York qui va dire tiens, je
vais essayer de trouver une solution à
Gaza. Moi euh quand on sort de la guerre
du Kuwait, on est convaincu puisqu'on a
vaincu la 4e armée du monde, j'ai jamais
su qui était la 3è, mais on a vaincu la
4e armée du monde en 120h. Donc on se
dit, on a un moyen militaire si tu veux
de s'instituer comme gendarme de la
planète. Bon et effectivement euh dans
la décennie 90, on va faire une
vingtaine d'interventions militaires à
chaque fois avec les de bonnes
conscience qui occupe les occidentaux.
C'est-à-dire nous sommes le bien et on a
une force armée, donc on va contribuer à
la résolution. Je prends l'exemple de la
démocratie, on va apporter la
démocratie, les écoles pour les petites
filles,
pas obligatoirement mais les petites
filles, ça apparaît après. Mais si tu
veux l'idée que par exemple en
Yougoslavie,
j'en ai parlé récemment avec Vedrine
parce que tu sais que Mitteran au départ
était
Hubert Vedrine.
Il était Mitteran était réticent parce
que il voyait les risques, comment dire
? Il pensait que si on pouvait sauver la
Fédération titiste, c'était le moindre
mal. Bon, en plus après évidemment il
aurait préféré si tu veux qu'il y ait
une solution qui essaie de conforter ce
qui se ce qui existait
mais la Slovénie va devenir
indépendante, reconnue par l'Allemagne
et cetera. Ça va être une espèce de
débandade et que il finalement va
éclater le le système. Ensuite, tu vas
t'ancrer dans une espèce de dans une
espèce de référence historique. Tu vas
donc avoir les mecs qui disent "Ah mais
les les croates, on les connaît. C'est
les usach, c'était des alliés des
nazis."
et l'autre qui vont dire "Oui oui mais
nous les sermes, on les connaî, ils ont
été nos alliés pendant la guerre de 14,
tu vois le référent historique quoi."
Alors prenons le cas des parce que c'est
exactement le même genre d'accusation
qu'on fait sur l'Ukraine aujourd'hui.
Quand tu as été l'objet de répression,
l'ennemi de ton ennemi devient ton ami.
Donc les mecs ont fourni des brigades
qui ont combattu avec les nazis, y
compris en URSS et évidemment qui ont
massacré du Serbe à volonté. La même
chose en Ukraine, les mecs sortent de
l'ollo de mort, c'est-à-dire d'une
extermination par la famine avec des cas
de cannibalisme et cetera et cetera.
Pratiqué par l'exunion soviétique,
pratiqué par Staline avec l'idée qu'on
monopolisé toutes les récoltes de
l'Ukraine qui est cette formidable
région, comment dire pays d'une richesse
absolue sur le plan agricole pour payer
l'industrialisation de l'Union
soviétique au prix de de comment dire
d'horreur encore une fois parce qu'on a
eu des cas de famille, des cas de
cannibalisme et cetera. Bon,
tu es ukrainien, tu vois arriver les
Allemands, les Allemands sont des
libérateurs et donc tu vas fournir une
assistance à celui qui est l'ennemi de
ton ennemi. Et donc la cible première
des des
brigades banderas, ça va être
d'exterminer les commissaires politiques
de l'Union soviétique. Donc tu vois,
après coup, il est facile de dire ou là
là, ils ont été nazis. Mais encore une
fois, tu ne comprends la chose que tu la
comprends localement, pas avec des
concepts théoriques, tu vois, où c'était
effectivement euh euh le mal absolu
était d'être nazi. Bon, nous-même, on a
été collaborateur si je me souviens
bien. Tu sais qu'on a eu un cas très
intéressant parce que le procès de
Nuremberberg, donc tout le monde a
connaît la logique. On va juger les
chefs de guerre nazi pour ce qu'ils ont
fait, déportation, extermination,
bombardement des populations civile et
cetera.
Pendant le procès de Durenberg, on
reprend la recolonisation. C'est-à-dire
qu'il va y avoir le massacre de Cétif en
Algérie et il va y avoir le massacre
d'ongle l'amiral d'argentlieu qui était
un résistant, un gauliste qui avait
rejoint de Gaul à Londres. Tu vois
comment le yatus se fait entre la cause
pour laquelle on s'est battu et puis
tout à coup la nouvelle problématique de
la recolonisation. Alors à Tokyo,
l'autre version du procès fait sur les
les comment dire les responsables de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale, on va y
associer
un un juge indien qui s'appelle Narendra
Pal. Et ce juge indien, il est très
intéressant parce que il va complètement
faire dérailler le système. Bon, le
système c'était effectivement les cinq
grands qui qui accusaient le Japon
d'être responsable et cetera et cetera.
Et Paul leur dit "Mais attendez, vous
avez mis le Japon sous embargot quand il
a envahi la Chine et c'était un embargo
international. Donc vous n'étiez pas
parti prement à ce conflit. Pourquoi
avoir mis un embargo ?" Donc s'ils ont
réagi contre cet embargo, il faut aussi
comprendre leur raison. Première chose.
Deuxième raison, il dit "Vous êtes en
train d'accuser les Japonais pour des
crimes qui n'existaient pas les coups
qu'ils ont été commis." C'est-à-dire
vous êtes en train d'appliquer un effet
rétroactif sur du droit, ce qui est
quand même interdit en matière de droit.
3è remarque, il dit "Mais quand vous
accusez les Japonais d'avoir envahi le
l'Indochine, mais l'Indochine de Vichi
était allié des Allemands, donc c'est
pas une invasion." Et donc ce type a
complètement fait dérailler, si tu veux
ce procès de Tokyo parce que il disait
"Mais vous êtes des colonisateurs, vous
êtes en train de reposer reprocher aux
Japonais d'avoir fait comme vous." Bon,
là où ça devient intéressant, c'est que
PAL qui avait une espèce de logique très
très intéressante, il devient la base du
révisionnisme japonais. C'estàd que
japonais disent "Voyez que ça n'était
pas responsable."
Tu vois le la dangosité des idées même
si on le sont légitime parce queencore
une fois c'est la fabrication de
l'opinion qui prime. Donc tu as
effectivement au Japon une école
révisionniste qui disent "Mais non, nous
avons été contraints de faire la
guerre."
Ça est contraint de faire la guerre là.
Ah bah oui, bien sûr.
Les méthodes d'employé
à 5 10 ans, si je prends la formulation
de l'arithmétique de la rébellion,
tous les gamins, tous les gamins qui se
prennent des bombes sur la tête parce
que il y a des cages d'armes sous leurs
pieds, il y a des caages d'armes sous
les hôpitaux, il y a des cages d'armes
derrière les centres culturels, il y a
des cages d'armes
Ouais. Ouais.
Est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que le fait
de raser une région, de faire déplacer
la population pour choper les les
terroristes,
c'est productif infineré ? Est-ce qu'il
y a pas une expérience
dans l'histoire où on a pu euh
se débarrasser de ce genre de de choses
?
Dans la phase des guerres de
décolonisation, il y a très peu
d'exemples de guerres
de décolonisation des guerres de
résistance à une comment dire une
révolte coloniale.
Le seul exemple si je me souviens bien
doit être la Malaisie mais parce que
c'était une une comment dire une
insurrection de la communauté chinoise
de Malaisie si tu veux qu'il n'ait pas
le soutien de la communauté malaise.
Donc les anglais ont pu effectivement
mener une politique assez ciblée de
répression. C'est le seul exemple à ma
connaissance, mais je me trompe
peut-être, de cas de guerre de
décolonisation qui a qui a abouti
ensuite à un processus logique
d'indépendance et cetera. Bon euh le
aucune des guerres de décolonisation ne
s'est terminée par la par la victoire du
colonisateur.
46 on commence la guerre du Vietnam, la
guerre d'Indochine, on appelait ça nous
à l'époque. Les Américains vont
enchaîner avec le même résultat. Et
encore une fois, c'est pas la
supériorité technologique qui va les
faire gagner puisque finalement ils sont
ils ont bombardé, tu sais que les
Américains ont déversé sur le Nord
Vietnam plus de bombes au kilomètres
carrés que les alliés pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale sur l'Allemagne. Tu vois
ce que je veux dire ? C'est-à-dire que
le Vietnam Nord a été bombardé plus
systématiquement et plus
méthéthodiquement que ce qu'on avait
fait sur l'Allemagne. Bon, à la fin de
la guerre,
les Américains s'étonnaient de la
résistance du peuple allemand en dépit
de toutes les campagnes de bombardement.
Tu sais qu'à une certaine époque,
la cible des bombardements devenait les
villes allemandes au-delà des des cibles
militaire puisque il y a eu par exemple
le bombardement de Drez qui était un
bombardement qui devait tétaniser
l'opinion publique allemande. Bon avec
bombe incendiaire et cetera et cetera.
Et donc les Américains se sont demandés
mais pourquoi est-ce que les Allemands
résistaient jusqu'au bout ? Euh
et ils ont demandé à des sociologues de
travailler là-dessus. Alors, c'est très
c'est très intéressant parce que les
sociologues ont fait une très longue
étude pour aboutir à une conclusion
assez simple, c'est quand tu es sous la
bombardement, tu te solidarise avec
celui qui te protège, pas avec celui qui
te bombarde. Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? Bon, donc
le s il protège que dal là. Bon
le Hamas il protège personne il pas
avant les bombardements il
eu de la nourriture de l'argent pour
avoir le le les les femmes.
Non mais tu peux prendre le bombardement
au sens figuré du terme c'est-à-dire
qu'effidement celui qui te fait subir la
situation qu'encore une fois comme le
ghetto de Varsovie c'est celui-là que tu
vas rendre responsable effectivement de
ton malheur.
Donc on va pas faire faire si tu veux
dans le détail dans la fioriture. Par
contre,
le
encore une fois, c'est c'est ce
cette fabrication de l'opinion qui me
qui me fascine parce que je comprends
que l'opinion israélienne a besoin d'un
acte de vengeance de la même façon que
l'opinion américaine après le 11
septembre avait besoin d'une guerre. Et
tu vois ce besoin d'une guerre, c'est il
faut se venger, nous avons été victimes.
Bon
le ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
ensuite après l'Afghanistan, première
étape si tu veux, il va donc y avoir la
guerre en Irak. Bon la guerre en Irak,
tu connais l'épisode Chirak s'y oppose.
French bashing aux États-Unis,
scandaleux, on va renommer les frites,
on va parler des Français qui étaient
des lâches, enfin tout ce que tu peux
imaginer et cetera.
Shirac était le dernier gauliste du
système français. C'est-à-dire le type,
il disait "Non, on va avoir une guerre
qui va provoquer plus de dégâts qu'elle
va apporter de solutions." Je signale
que Shirak avait deux caractéristiques.
Il avait fait la guerre d'Algérie, il
s'engueulait, paraît-il, avec JS de
temps en temps sur ce sujet-là. Et
ensuite, il avait voyagé. George Bouche
était allé au Mexique une fois quand il
était étudiant. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? C'est-à-dire que cette
appréhension du monde, c'est pas d'être
sur une terre plate dont le centre,
c'est de comprendre que la terre est
ronde et qu'il y a des gens qui pensent
pas comme nous. Il y a un diplomate
Gourd Montagne qui a fait un bouquin qui
est extraordinaire parce qu'il
s'intitule "Les autres ne pensent pas
comme nous". Tu vois ce que je veux dire
? C'est-à-dire tu es vraiment dans un
système où notre normalisation telle
qu'on l'a pensé nous avec beaucoup de
bonnes raisons, on était les
démocraties, tout ce que tu veux,
faisait que on ne comprenait pas
l'autre. il lui on ne lui reconnaissait
pas une légitimité sauf à la fin de
guerre qui effectivement finissait par
épuisement par s'arrêter. Donc on est
dans la même situation aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire que si effectivement on
sort de cette de cette horreur qu'on qu'
a commis le Hamas par une répression qui
va la dépasser en entité en identité,
c'est-à-dire tu vas avoir plus de
Palestiniens qui vont être massacrés que
de juifs n'ont été tués. J'ai fait le
calcul depuis la première intifada si je
me souviens bien.
Il y a environ 1500 Israéliens qui ont
été tués. Ça vient d'où les chiffres ?
Pardon ?
Les chiffres
c'est c'est moi qui ai fait les agrégats
depuis la première intifada. Il y a
grosso
aggrégat venait d'où ?
Pardon ?
Les agrégats de données venaient d'où ?
Bah écoute c'est les données que si tu
veux ça ça va de ce côté-là il y a pas
besoin de sourcer si tu veux. Bon euh
il faut toujours sourcer hein.
Pardon ?
Il faut toujours sourcer. Oui, mais
enfin bon, je peux te citer un site
américain du Schmol Bloc qui va être à
l'université de Caroline du Sud. Non,
c'est pas c'est pas ça encore une fois.
Encore une fois, il y a des chiffres qui
sont relativement connus et tu fais si
je vais pas te les donner à l'unité
près, mais grosso modo, tu dois avoir,
mais si mes souvenirs sont bons, à peu
près 1500 Israéliens qui ont été tués et
10000 Palestiniens qui ont été tués.
C'est-à-dire qu'à chaque fois la
répression était plus forte que l'acte
de terrorisme. Et encore une fois, tu es
dans cette logique perverse.
C'est-à-dire si ne sors pas par une
négociation, tu auras toujours cette
mécanique qui fera que renaîtra un autre
terroriste qui va se sentir mobilisé
pour aller massacrer. Penchons-nous sur
le cas du Titchen Chen et Lingou. Là où
on a aucune responsabilité, on est dans
une espèce de mobilisation
qui fait que n'importe quel individu sur
n'aime pas notamment dans le le
terrorisme islamiste, il va se sentir
mobilisé pour prendre les les armes.
Bon, donc il faut s'attaquer à ce
salafisme. Or, tu t'aperçois
qu'effectivement il y a un certain
nombre de partis politiques qui font du
misérabilisme. Je citerai pas la France
insoumise, mais enfin leur posture à
l'égard de ce qui se passe à l'égard du
salafisme, c'est consiste à faire de la
victimisation. les pauvres types c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas de notre faute,
c'est pas de leur faute et cetera et
cetera. Je laisse tomber le calcul
électoral, ça m'intéresse pas mais c'est
pour dire que tu vois bien qu'on est sur
un système dans laquel la fabrication de
l'opinion est essentielle et cette
fabrication de l'opinion, il y a des
méthodes pour la pour la fabriquer. Donc
le
je reprends si tu veux un exemple qui me
paraît qui me paraît intéressant.
Début du 20e siècle, Occident Triomphant
diffuse sur la planète sa culture. Il va
faire deux guerres mondiales, une avec
20 millions de morts, la deuxième avec
50 millions de morts. Bon, ça fait un
gros bilan quand même. Les intellectuels
de l'époque commencent à critiquer ce
système- là, c'est-à-dire ce système qui
va donner naissance au fascisme, qui va
donner naissance à des guerres mondiales
et cetera en étant totalement aveugle
sur ce qui se passe de l'autre côté du
réseau de fer.
Alors, on va avoir donc une espèce de
crise de conscience de l'Occident qui
effectivement s'installe dans cette idée
que ayant enchaîner deux guerres
mondiales et les guerres de
décolonisation, il y a effectivement une
pénitence à observer. Bon,
la traduction de cette pénitence, ça va
être la création de l'État d'Israël.
Bois un coup de flotte. Il y a des
copains qui disent que tu as la langue
qui colle.
Que quoi ? bois un peu d'eau.
Ah oui, le
tu vois l'idée c'est que on va
reconnaître les l'effroid l'effroyable
massacre qui a été la choa et on va
reconnaître la nécessité de compenser
cette choa par la création de l'État
d'Israël. On est dans une époque de
colonisation donc il suffit que Londres
et Paris décident que l'État d'Israël
sera situé effectivement dans la zone du
mandat britannique et cetera avec un
argument historique, on était là il y a
3000 ans. Donc c'est à nous.
argument que tu vas retrouver chez les
Arméniens pour le haut Carabac en disant
"Oui, ça c'était une gé qui était
arménienne chez nous, donc il faut qu'on
le récupère." Mais si tu fais la carte
du monde il y a 50 ans, 60 ans, 70 ans,
tu te rends compte du nombre de
territoires qu'il faudrait redessiner.
Donc il y a un argument historique qui
est valide dans certains cas qui est pas
valide dans d'autres.
Deuxième chose, évidemment va on va
cultiver l'idée qu'après tout il y a une
responsabilité
des des occidentaux à l'égard de la
communauté juive et donc cette forme de
compensation va prendre la forme de la
création de l'État d'Israël. Mais tu te
rends bien compte qu'en l'occurrence les
Palestiniens qui n'ont rien à voir avec
la choix vont payer la facture. Bon, on
est donc bien dans quelque chose dans
lequel on se dit "Oui, mais enfin là,
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on y fasse
? Il fallait bien qu'il ait quelqu'un
qui trinque. Et avant qu'on puisse
reconnaître une légitimité à la au
Palestiniens, il a fallu du temps. Je
laisse de côté le fait qu'aucun des
États arabes n'avait envie de se de se
préoccuper des Palestiniens. C'était
normalement la Jordanie qui devait les
accuser, mais comme tu le sais, la
dynastie jordanienne, c'est des bédoins.
Les accueillir,
pardon, de les accueillir. Oui. Euh les
la dynastie le roi de Jordanie est un
bédoin. La communauté palestinienne et
la masse de la population. Mais enfin,
ils avaient pas l'intention de les
accueillir parce que ça déstabilisait
complètement le royaume jordanien. Et
rappelle-toi l'épisode de septembre
noir. C'est-à-dire quand il faudra va
falloir absolument empêcher que les
Palestiniens sous la forme de l'OLP
n'interviennent en Jordanie, il va y
avoir un des massacres les plus
effroyables de de Palestiniens qu'on
puisse imaginer. Donc la trahison des
États-rabes, je ne m'end pas là-dessus,
mais ils avaient une cause à partir de
ce moment-là puisque toutes les formes
de démocratisation qui se passait dans
le monde arabe, à chaque fois c'était ah
là, attendez, vous êtes en train
d'affaiblir la cause arabe. La cause
arabe étant la destruction de l'État
d'Israël. Tu vois l'hypocrisie du
système, toute réforme, toute réforme
démocratique, toute manifestation
sociale, c'était attention, vous êtes en
train d'oublier la cause sacrée qui est
la libération de la Palestine.
Euh je n'insiste pas là-dessus. Mais
enfin, tu vois bien qu'il y a une espèce
de fabrication de comment dire
argumentaire, une trahison fantastique
des États-rabes à l'égard de ce que de
ce qu'a été la cause palestinienne. Donc
euh tu vois, il y a des il y a des des
guerres qu'on qu'on résout comme ça euh
parce que on pensait à l'époque que la
Terre était plate et que l'Occident
était le centre, quoi.
Comment ça va se terminer cette histoire
là ? On va avoir l'Iran qui va
rencontrer du moins qui va rentrer
encore plus dans la danse. On va avoir
des bateaux coulés dans la mer rouge,
des bateaux coulé dans le des trit
d'ormouse. On va avoir le la sortie du
pétrole saoudien bloqué par les Iraniens
dans le D3 d'Ormous par en coulant trois
quatre bateaux.
On va se retrouver avec des millions de
personnes dans la nature déplacé fâché
qui va ensuite faire des bébés stressés.
Tu connais le phénomène d'épigénétique ?
tuexposes des femmes enceintes à des
situations stressantes. Le gamin il en
sort pas indemn, il traîne ça toute sa
vie. Donc le le
je sais pas
la communauté internationale.
Ouais,
elle voit bien que ça je sais que
communauté internationale maintenant ça
fait un peu plastique Twitch. Euh
mais la communauté
elle fait quoi ? Et c'est parce que on
voit bien qu'il y a des gamins dans tous
les sens qui se font massacrer.
Mais la communauté internationale
n'existe pas. Les communautés
internationales a un agenda qui dépend
de la capacité de mobilisation d'une
crise, des acteurs de cette crise et
cetera. La crise la plus grave
aujourd'hui, c'est la crise du Congo. 20
millions de morts. La crise du Congo, si
tu vois, nous on s'est occupé du Rwanda.
Le Congo, on avait quand même pas le
courage de s'occuper du Congo. Au Congo,
il doit y avoir à peu près 120 milices
diverses si tu veux qui sont qui se
massacrent allègrement et personne,
aucun pays, ni les Russes ni les
Américains ont envie de se préoccuper du
Congo. Bon, donc il y a bien une
question d'agenda et l'ONU peut très
bien désigner un monsieur au Congo tout
ce que tu veux imaginer mais enfin
personne ne fournira les moyens de
résoudre cette crise. Donc il y a
effectivement
un risque grave que la chose dérive mais
la communauté internationale ne peut pas
être la solution. Elle peut pas quand on
quand on a fait la Yougoslavie, la
communauté internationale a mandaté des
forces françaises et britanniques pour
aller à Sarayevo
en interposition pour empêcher que la
ville assiégée ne tombe. Bon on pensait
que la seule apparition des soldats
français et anglais en en casque bleu
allait calmer tout le monde. Ça n'a rien
calmé du tout. On a perdu, je crois une
cinquantaine de types en Yogoslavie qui
étaient tués par des snipers. Ils ont
ils ont raté BHL, j'ai remarqué à chaque
fois.
Pas de PL comme ça.
Non, mais si tu veux le la façon dont tu
penses un conflit est essentielle parce
que tu crois que tes tes moyens vont
permettre de calmer les belligérants.
Or, on était dans un système si vous
voulez où c'était construit après la
mort de Tito. Toute une espèce
d'animosité qui était encré dans
l'histoire. C'est-à-dire que les Serbes
avaient été à l'époque de Pierre Ier de
Serbie, la puissance dominante les
Croates avaient été dominées et cetera
et cetera et cetera. Les Slovaes se
considère en dehors de tout ça. Donc
toute cette problématique là si tu veux,
on ne cherchait pas à la défendre.
Enfin, en tout cas, on pouvait hésiter
entre si on sauvait la Youugoslavie
tititiste, on peut-être éviter les
horreurs qu'on a commis. Bon, puis
finalement, la chose ne s'est pas passé
comme le souhaitait Miteran. Et donc
finalement, il va quand même faire ce
voyage à à Sarayevo pour montrer queil
est il est concerné par ce qui est en
train de se passer. Mais personne
n'avait les moyens d'empêcher une crise
de cette violence là. Quoi ?
Comment fait passer le message aux
Israéliens que c'est peut-être pas la
bonne méthode de tout raser ?
Tu peux pas faire passer un message
comme ça. Tu peux pas. Regarde le cas
des États-Unis après le 11 septembre. Il
fallait une guerre. Il fallait une
guerre. Comment vous vous rendez compte
? les deux symboles de la puissance
américaine détruite par des Arabes qui
se jettent avec des avions, c'est-à-dire
des gens qui sont capables de sacrifier
leur vie pour comment dire détruire la
puissance américaine, en tout cas
symboliquement la détruire. 3000 morts,
enfin tout ce que tu connais, des images
filmées sur la planète entière, tout le
monde a vécu en direct si tu veux la
destruction des tours. Donc il y a un
moment où l'opinion publique,
comment dire déborde de haine et déborde
la nécessité d'une guerre de vengeance,
hein. Bon, donc tu connais le déroulé,
après il va y avoir l'Afghanistan, puis
tout de suite après, il va y avoir
l'Irak. Alors, l'Irak, c'est très
intéressant pour deux raisons. D'abord
parce que le lien était pas évident.
Encore une fois euh 15 saoudiens sur 19
terroristes, il y avait pas d'Iraakiens,
il y avait pas de d'Iraniens, il y avait
pas de nord-coréen. Donc le l'idée de
faire en en janvier 2002 un discours de
George Bouche pour désigner l'axe du mal
avec ces trois pays-là, ça te montre
qu'il y a des forces derrière George
Bouche qui avait un plan tout près. Bon,
dans ce plan tout près, il y avait deux
acteurs importants, deux courants
idéologiques très importants qui étaient
les néoconservateurs. né auconservateur
eux se disaient nous avons les moyens de
la victoire donc il faut donner un bon
coup dernier coup de collier militaire
pour permettre la stabilité la la
comment dire la sécurité en Israël
et donc ils vont dire ben après
l'Afghanistan ils vont choisir l'Irak
parce que l'Irak restait un des derniers
socialismes arabes avec la Syrie et
cetera.
Euh l'autre courant sont les
néovangéliques. Les néovangéliques,
c'est la version radicale du
protestantisme américain. Le protestant
américain, il faut te souvenir donc
quand arrivent les pères fondateurs,
c'est la terre promise. On arrive aux
États-Unis et donc on va construire la
société parfaite. Et n'oubliez pas que
c'était des protestants persécutés par
les autres. Et donc ils vont considérer
que ce territoire là, ils vont pouvoir y
construire la société imaginaire et
parfaite qu'ils ont en tête. Bon, il
commence à s'inquiéter quand arrivent
les premiers catholiques, c'est-à-dire
qu'on commence à migrer des Espagnols,
des Italiens, des Irlandais, des
Sud-Américains, parce queà ce moment-là,
ils ont l'impression que le modèle est
en train de faillir. Et donc se passe
une chose qui s'appelle les rencontres
d'Aroucha qui sont des rencontres où
justement vont se cristalliser cette
espèce de néovangélisme, c'est-à-dire un
protestantisme radical qui disent "Mais
non, ces gens-là sont pas de chez nous."
Bon et donc ces néovangéliques, ils ont
une vision théologique de la planète,
c'est-à-dire ils disent et c'est une
raison qu'ils ont soutenu devant bouche
que si euh le grand Israël est
constitué, c'est l'étape indispensable
annoncée dans la Bible pour le retour du
Messie.
Donc le grand Israël c'est du Nil
jusqu'à le frat.
Alors les éradicaux juifs, c'est du Nil
jusqu'à le frat. Ça c'était la Bible au
sens littéral du terme. Ils disent d'un
flavalotte, on précise pas lesquels,
mais enfin on imagine c'est cela. les
néoangéliques que leur postulat est
aussi théologique mais ils disent une
fois reconstitué le grand Israël à ce
moment-là le Messie pourra revenir.
Alors ce qui est rigolo c'est que pour
les juifs le Messie n'est jamais arrivé
mais pour les les chrétiens il est
arrivé déjà une fois. Donc comme
Netaniaahou avait besoin de ses
néovangéliques, si tu veux un jour qu'il
y avait une discussion qui tournait un
peu d' Bouddha avec eux, il a dit
"Écoutez, le jour où le Messie arrivera,
on lui posera une seule question. Est-ce
que c'est la première fois ? Est-ce que
c'est la deuxième fois que tu viens il
s'est sorti de la difficulté comme ça.
Mais tu vois ce que je veux dire ? Cette
alliance contre
Ouais. Oui, c'est vrai. L'anecdote est
juste. Ouais. Donc tu vois cette
alliance contre nature, c'est-à-dire
avec des gens qui ont des ressorts
intellectuels qu'on ne mesure pas. On
n'est plus dans la gamme de l'est ouest
où on se disait telle crise va être
instrumentalisée par l'autre et donc il
a tel allié sur place. On n'est plus
dans ce domaineel. On est dans un
domaine où chaque crise a sa dynamique
propre, a retrouvé sa dynamique propre.
Et effectivement, c'est là que le
complexe militaire intellectuel,
c'est-à-dire tous ces gens qui vont
apparaître sur les plateaux télé vont
dire "Non, non, la crise importante
c'est celle-là. D'ailleurs, j'en viens,
je connais les gentils, je connais les
méchants. Donc voilà, c'est un c'est une
transformation euh stratégique assez
assez essentielle qui est en train de se
passer.
Et la guerre Israël Gaza,
malheureusement, si on laisse aller
jusqu'au bout, c'est-à-dire cette
politique d'extermination avec la guerre
dans les tunnels et pass audessus au
dessous des tunnels, il y a des mecs
quand même hein, il faut quand même se
dire ça. Déjà enfermés parce que
l'Égypte ne laisse passer qu'au compte
goutte, si tu veux, l'aide humanitaire
mais surtout pas des hommes. Euh
on on on il faut pas qu'on laisse faire
un espèce de massacre de cette
importance là, c'est pas possible. J'ai
entendu ce matin une interview de Gérard
Aro qui a été notre ambassadeur en
Israël qui disait "Mais ce qui se passe
en Z Jordanie, c'est scandaleux. C'est
scandaleux et c'est un ambassadeur. Pour
qu'un ambassadeur se utilise ce genre de
terme, ça veut dire que vraiment il l'a
constaté. Mais qu'est-ce qu'il a pu en
dire
? Un ancien ambassadeur,
ancien ambassadeur en Israël, ça veut
dire qu'est-ce qu'il a pu en dire quand
il était en poste ? C'est ça ma
question. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il a pu faire passer de ce
qu'il constatait ?
Quand la France envoie notre
deuxième plus grand navire, navire
hôpital, tu as suivi cette histoire ?
Genre le le le deuxième navire plus
grand derrière le Charles Legal envoyé
là-bas navire hôpital capacité en lit.
Si mes souvenirs sont bons, c'est 60
personnes.
Il y a pas le personnel. On peut prendre
que
de de blessés graves. On passe pas pour
des touristes, on passe pas pour des
connards.
Je connais pas l'épisode, je suis désolé
là vraiment, je connais pas le truc. Je
sais pas, ça me dit rien. Je sais pas
l'Iran dans tout ça,
on en fait quoi ?
Ben l'Iran, il faut l'apprendre dans son
continuité encore une fois historique.
Le temps long est beaucoup plus
explicatif que le
Tu crois la théorie que les Israéliens
vont bombarder au nucléaire ?
La mer connerie est perpétuellement
sainte, hein.
Oh, terrible.
Mais écoute, qu'est-ce que tu veux que
je te dise ? Je sais pas. S'il y a un
abruti, comme il y en a un d'ailleurs
dans le gouvernement israélien dont j'ai
oublié le nom, qui a dit il faut
utiliser le nucléaire sur Gaza. Il a été
vertement sanctionné. Il a été sorti du
conseil de défense, il a pas été
démissionné. Ça veut dire qu'il y a des
mecs qui sont capables d'exprimer ce
genre de point de vue radical et et
absolument ignoble.
C'est pas un mec du ministère de la
défense qui a dit aussi que c'était des
animaux ou je sais pas quoi,
je sais pas. Je sais pas. Mais enfin,
c'est pour te dire, tu vois, quand je te
dis la première connerie est
perpétuellement enceinte, c'est parce
que tu ne peux pas imaginer le degré de
bêtises que la violence vengeresse est
capable de déclencher. Voilà. Donc quand
Gérard Aarot dit une chose pareille, la
seule question que je me pose, c'est la
même que se me posait après le Rwanda.
C'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'il a pu faire
passer de ce qu'il constatait quand il
était en poste ? Est-ce qu'il a été
entendu ? Est-ce qu'on lui a dit
"Écoutez, est si grave après tout ?"
C'est le même truc que la DGSE dont je
te parlais.
Quand un système si tu veux, regarde, il
y en a un qui est extraordinaire, je le
cite dans le bouquin, le rapport Auin.
Le rapport Auin Auain est un inspecteur
général de l'éducation nationale à qui
on demande, je crois que c'est en 2001
ou 2002, de faire un point parce qu'il y
a des profs qui se plaignent si tu veux
de comportement de gosse qui contestent
l'enseignement et cetera et cetera. il
fait un relevé des actes de
désobéissance qui sont tous à base, si
tu veux islamistes, hein, c'est-à-dire
effectivement refus de de d'observer la
minute de silence, enfin des trucs comme
ça. Bon, et donc on est sur quelque
chose où un type va faire son travail.
Honnêtement,
on lui dit vous savez en ce moment, tu
vois, ça veut dire on a ouvert le
parapluie ou ben le rapport a été classé
sans suite. Sans suite. Il a fallu
Samuel Pat et Dominique Bernard pour
qu'on dise "Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans les écoles ?" Tu vois ce que je
veux dire ? C'est-à-dire cette espèce de
l'acheter. Il faut se rendre compte que
l'horizon temporel d'un politique c'est
les c'est les municipals. Il dit "Est-ce
que je gagne les municipales si je fais
c si je fais ça ? rappelle-toi
l'attitude de Hollande après les
attentats de 2015, il pose la question
de la déchéance de nationalité et
finalement il recule. Mais alors tu dis
"Mais attendez, il recule pourquoi ces
types étaient effectivement tu sais
qu'en matière de déchir socialité tu
peux pas déchoir tu peux pas faire
d'apatride ce qui est normal donc en
fait tu peux déchoir de nationalité un
homme qui a deux nationalités je vois
pas où était le problème. Il écrit après
avoir quitté ses fonctions que la seule
chose qui regrette c'est d'avoir posé
cette question là. Alors, tu te dis
"Mais attends, c'est nous qui l'avons
élu ce type." Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? Est-ce que tu Il y a un sujet si
tu veux qui me passionne en ce moment,
c'est le rôle des ONG
dans le la fabrication de l'opinion.
Les ONG ont été pendant longtemps une
espèce de conscience morale, si tu veux,
laquelle on reconnaissait une puissance
impressionnante de d'influence, de
préservation des droits de l'homme et
cetera et cetera. Bon,
deux exemples. Bon, d'abord la famille
Mogouchov devait être expulsée et sous
pression de du MRAP, d'Amnestie, je sais
plus qui la Ligue des droits de l'homme,
le préfet recule. Donc le gosse va
rester ici et il va ensuite assassiner
Samuel Bernard euh Philippe Bernard,
il va assassiner
Dominique Bernard, pardon. Euh, j'ai
cherché les excuses. Il y a aucune
excuse. Personne dit excusez-nous s'est
trompé. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Bon, je te prends un autre exemple très
intéressant, un type qui s'appelait
Ousama Atar. Ousamaar était un type, je
crois de la région de Rouan, qui part en
Syrie. Il part en Syrie combattre avec
Daesh et cetera et cetera. Et il est
faitonnier
finalement quand Daesh est décomposé que
il va être prisonnier chez au Kurdistan.
Pendant qu'il est là-bas, commence une
campagne d'opinion avec la famille de
Ousamaatar, avec l'appui de d'un certain
nombre d'ONG disant il est malade, il va
mourir, il faut le soigner, il faut le
rapatrier. C'est un citoyen français. Le
gouvernement français dit "Nous, c'est
du cas par cas, on va voir." Bon,
finalement, sous la pression notamment
des ONG parce que la famille où sommes à
tard, tu penses bien que c'était pas
elle qui pouvait faire plier le
gouvernement, on décide de raatrier le
type. Arrivé en France, il disparaît. Il
disparaît. On va le retrouver dans le
sud tunisien en train de faire du trafic
d'armes et il va être emporté à notre
affection par un drone américain une
fois retourné en Syrie.
Il y a que amnestie qui se soit excusé
en disant "Nous nous avons simplement
demandé qu'il soit soigné. Vous avez pas
demandé qu'il soit rapatrié. Aucune des
autres ONG ne s'est excusé. Tu vois ce
que veux dire ? Donc on est dans un
basculement dans la fabrication de
l'opinion. Cette conscience morale que
constituaient les ONG a pris beaucoup de
plombs dans l'aile et c'est évidemment
difficile de critiquer les ONG.
Revenons à l'Iran.
Hein ?
L'Iran ?
Ouais. Alors oui, l'Iran, pardon,
excuse-moi. Alors l'Iran, il faut le
prendre dans le temps long. D'abord,
première chose, c'est 3000 ans
d'histoire. C'est-à-dire que tu c'est
très ennuyeux de discuter avec des
Iraniens cultivés parce que quand tu
leur parles de ton histoire anstique, si
tu te veux, ils te disent "Oui, ça c'est
une mythologie qui est venue de chez
nous, la culte de Mitra qui a donné au
christianisme." Donc ils sont pénibres
parce que si tu veux, ils ont
l'impression ils te donnent l'impression
qu'il une histoire plus ancienne que la
nôtre. Mais enfin, pourquoi j'insiste
là-dessus ? Parce que
un peu vrai quand même, non ?
Pardon ? C'est un peu vrai quand même.
Ah bah oui oui oui. Non mais justement
c'est pour ça que je te dis là-dessus
parce que tu vas avoir une identité
iranienne qui évidemment va se crisper
quand le pays est attaqué. C'est-à-dire
tu vas te retrouver avec des gens qui
vont être d'accord avec moi. Euh le euh
je te la fait brève quand il y a la
révolution quand il y a la révolution
les les gardiens de la révolution vont
attaquer l'ambassade des États-Unis. tu
sais, ils vont prendre des otages et
donc ils vont euh
coopération comm télécommandé ou pas,
j'en sais strictement mais peu importe,
ça crée cette situation où effectivement
des diplomates violation de la
convention de Viennent, ils sont fait
prisonniers. Quand les types prennent
l'ambassade, ils s'aperçoivent qu'ils
étaient en train de déchiqueter tous les
documents secrets défenses. Donc les
Iraniens vont ramasser tout ce qu'ils
ont trouvé comme papier. Ils vont les
confier à des tisseuses de tapis qui
vont reconstituer des documents. Ils
vont reconstituer des documents qui
démontraient toutes les ingérences de
des États-Unis dans la vie politique
iranienne à l'époque du chat. Alors, tu
te dis qu'est-ce qui viole la convention
de Vienne ? C'est le fait de se mêler
des affaires intérieures d'un pays ou
c'est de prendre des otages ? Tu vois
comment le problème juridique peut être
posé dans un sens ou dans l'autre ?
Bref, il va donc y avoir le Saddam
Hussein du coin qui connaît bien le CG1.
il vient faire le tour des capitales
européennes et américaines en disant
"Moi, je vais vous débarrasser des
Iraniens, mais simplement est-ce que
vous vous engagez à me soutenir ?" Et
donc, on va glisser dans cette guerre
Iran Irak 8 ans 800000 morts je crois ou
quelque chose comme ça. Peut-être mes
chiffres sont-ils nécessités de mettre à
jour. Mais c'est une guerre qui se
caractérise par le fait qu'on va
soutenir l'agresseur et mettre sous
embarg l'agresser. Tu sais que l'embargo
concernait les Iraniens mais pas les les
irakiens. Et comme ça ça n'allait pas
aussi vite que Saddam Hussein le
pensait, on va même fournir des
navigateurs sur les super étendards
tirés de la marine nationale pour aller
les aider à bombarder les pétroliers
iraniens.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est-à-dire qu'on est dans un système
dans lequel quand tu es iranien, tu te
dis "Mais quelle confiance vais-je avoir
? dans cette communauté internationale,
celle qui considère que c'est moi qui
doit être mis sous embargot et donner
des armes à l'agresseur.
Et tu sais qu'à ce moment-là, Saddam
Hussein était le grand modernisateur du
monde arabe. C'est quand il va envahir
le C qui va devenir tout à coup le
nouvel Hitler. Tu vois, il faut faire
attention parce que des fois on peut
changer de catégorie comme ça.
le droit international,
toutes ces réglementations censées nous
prévenir de nos instincts les plus
primitifs,
bah
tout le monde tout le monde, permets-moi
l'expression, tout le monde s'essuit un
peu les fesses avec ou l'instrumentalise
ou militarise à son écoute, quand on
crée la le principe de la Cour pénale
internationale, courale internationale
qui justement doit permettre de juger
des responsables
sans retir,
les États-Unis unis le la Russie.
Donc tu te dis bon ben ça va, c'est
bien. Donc il y a que les petits pays
qui peuvent passer dans la compéénale
internationale.
Donc tu peux pas faire confiance à un
système comme celui-là. C'est un système
de rapport de force. Je te dis je sais
pas si je t'ai cité cet exemple mais
quand on adopte la convention
internationale des droits de l'homme
convention onusienne les cinq pays
signataires,
c'est la Russie de Staline, les
États-Unis racistes et
ségrégationnistes, les deux grandes
puissances coloniales que sont la France
et la Grande-Bretagne et la Chine de
Thangai Cheek. C'est-à-dire c'est faites
ce que je dis, faites pas ce que je
fais. Le droit international ne m'est
pas applicable. Tu vois ce que je veux
dire ? Donc oui, il faut continuer dans
cette voie-là. J'ai peu d'espoir mais
enfin il faut continuer.
On s'éloigne un peu pour en revenir
après. On en est où avec le conflit euh
russo-rainien ? Euh
ben le conflit russo-rainien encore une
fois là si tu veux il faut le prendre
dans sa dans sa durée. C'est-à-dire
bon quand l'URSS explose tu sais en
général reste en place des apparats chic
pur produit du système qui vont être à
la tête d'un certain nombre d'états
nouvellement apparus. Ça va être en
Azerbaïdjan, ça va être en
Cubbiélorussie, ça va être en Ukraine et
cetera. Bref, il y a la révolution de
Maidane, c'est-à-dire que tout à coup,
si tu veux, le mec va perdre les
élections parce qu'il y a quand même des
élections organisées. Donc va apparaître
à ce moment-là une espèce d'identité
ukrainienne qui va se manifester dans
les urnes. Et puis une des premières
mesures de ce nouvel gouvernement au
moment de la révolution de Maidan, ça
veut dire doréavant la langue
officielle, c'est l'Ukrainien. Bon, je
parle pas le russe ni l'Ukrainien, mais
enfin visiblement ça a chagriné la
partie
ouest est de la de l'Ukraine où vivent
des populations russophones.
Faut dire que les populations russines
c'était comme les pieds noirs en
Algérie, c'est-à-dire c'était les
anciens des représentants de l'ancienne
puissance coloniale qui tout à coup se
trouvent rétrogradé au rang de
population inférieure. Et donc en dépit
des efforts de la France et de la
Grande-Bretagne pour trouver une
solution avec les les accords de Minsk
si tu veux il va y avoir déclenchement
de violence dont je connais pas
l'origine mais enfin grosso modo avant
l'intervention russe on était déjà à
14000 morts quand même dans le conflit
ce qui effectivement laisse des traces
et donc cette problématique je défends
mes mes minorités quand elles sont à
l'extérieur c'est la Russie est pas le
seul pays à avoir utilisé cet
argumentaire hein pour intervenir mais
c'est vrai que on a des deux côtés côté
des gens qui sont pas très clairs si tu
veux sur la manière dont ils ont géré
cette solution de crise. Peut-être
avait-il besoin de la guerre parce que
encore une fois ça légitime le pouvoir
en place parce que ça permet de durcir
de renforcer l'unité nationale. Mais
enfin
tu sais par exemple pour Gaza, tu sors
souvent l'argument Gaza regardez
l'argent qu'on y a déversé, il y a de la
corruption partout et cetera. L'Ukraine
n'est pas très bien placée chez
Transparency internationale si tu veux
en matière de de corruption. Et l'aide
qu'on donne là, si tu veux, est une aide
qui effectivement se perd dans des
réseaux secondaires. Et donc ça entre
Zelanski qui est tout à coup l'espèce de
personnage chevalier blanc et cetera qui
se bat pour son pays et puis ce qui se
passe autour de lui, c'est vrai qu'il y
a un moment où tu
il en a viré beaucoup quand même non ?
Il en a viré beaucoup de ceux qui
tapaient dans le pot de confiture, non ?
Ah oui oui oui. Mais si tu veux prends
l'exemple de Poutine. Poutine succède à
Yalsin qui était un ivrogne. Yals il est
arrivé à des conférences
internationales, il était complètement
bourré. Enfin moi. Donc si tu veux pour
la Russie l'époque de Yelsine c'est le
dépessage des richesses nationales par
les oligarques qui entouraient Yelsin.
Bon et donc les mecs vont se prendre de
tous les morceaux les charbonnages,
l'énergie machin et Poutine arrive, il
est le contreype de Delsine. Le mec il
est sain, il fait de la gymnastique,
fait exercice et cetera. Première
mesure, il tape sur un oligarque qui
s'appelait Kodorkovski. Bon, le mec
était milliardaire à 25 ans. J'aimerais
bien être milliardaire. Réussi,
pardon, une réussite.
Il avait réussi. Il avait pris tout
simplement le pétrole russe. Bon, donc
c'est vrai que ça fournit des réserves,
mais on va pas le créditer de ça. On va
dire attention, il a droit à un procès
équitable.
On se tait quand on est dans ce genre de
situation. Comment vas-tu espérer qu'un
système judiciaire qui s'est explosé
avec la leSS alors que le geste est
politiquement important ? Donc si tu
veux arriver derrière en disant "Oh là
là, mais attention, il a pas eu droit à
un procès et cetera." Non, il faut lui
reconnaître ça. Bon et donc le le
Poutine, il a probablement, moi je
connais pas suffisamment la Russie, mais
il a une certaine popularité. Il a une
certaine popularité et quand des gens le
disent comme par exemple Hélène Carrière
d'Ancos et que tu as des articles dans
le Figaro pour expliquer le clan des
cremelinologues ou des Poutinophiles, je
sais pas comment ils l'ont appelé, un
peu de dignité. Et quand quelqu'un a
travaillé pendant 40 ans sur un pays,
elle a peut-être probablement une
appréhension de l'opinion publique plus
forte que le mec qui va arriver en
disant euh Poutine c'est dégueulasse,
c'est scandaleux, machin. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? On est dans un système où
encore une fois cette fabrication de
l'opinion
euh accentué par la prééminence des
plateaux télé et cetera et puis par la
volonté de vouloir diaboliser de temps
en temps quelqu'un. Ça me fait toujours
un peu de bien quand on a réussi à
diaboliser quelqu'un.
Donc la clé de vous de tout ça, c'est
l'opinion publique.
Ah l'enjeu c'est l'opinion publique.
Oui.
Ou alors comment on fait pour endurcir
l'opinion publique ?
Pour durcir durcir endurcir l'opinion
publique ?
Ben tu ne peux que faire ton travail de
de spécialiste. Enfin que ton travail
d'expert encore une fois au bon sens du
terme, c'est-à-dire pas aller dans un
plateau télé pour effectivement pouvoir
montrer que tu es cher. Regarde le cas
du Covid. Regarde le cas du Covid. Le
plateau télé se sont peuplés de médecins
alors que personne ne savait rien de
cette maladie.
Donc tu t'aperçois que d'être invité sur
un plateau télé est une forme de
reconnaissance et donc que tu vas avoir
effectivement des gens qui vont défiler
pour devenir
le spécialiste de la maladie qu'on
connaît pas. Bon, tu retrouves la même
chose les
les Covid longtemps qu'on les connaît
hein.
Écoute, moi j'en sais rien. Je suis pas
médecin. Ce qui est certain que si tu
veux, on a pas touillé quand même
beaucoup sur le Covid au début. Bon,
mais tu avais quand même des gens qui
venaient expliquer ce qui était maladie
alors qu'il y avait aucune expérience
aucune encore une fois moi c'est le
système médiatique qui m'intéresse.
C'est le fait que tu puisses inviter des
gens qui vont venir sur le plateau télé
fort d'une espèce de labelle
effectivement un médecin donc tu te dis
que c'est quand même quelque chose de
sérieux et donc tu vas les avoir bon
mais ça veut dire que le système ne peut
pas faire d'auto sensure lui-même. Il
est obligé de recourir à ce qu'il a en
main. Je te prends un autre exemple.
Après le 11 septembre, le choc
traumatique aux États-Unis a été tel que
effectivement les Américains
se disaient "Mais pourquoi nous ?"
Alors, tu avais deux solutions pour
répondre à cette question. Soit c'était
de faire le bilan critique de l'Action
internationale des États-Unis, soit sont
apparus à ce moment-là des PSIS, ils ont
dit "Non, non, mais vous inquiétez pas,
vous vous êtes normal normaux, c'est
l'autre qui est fou." Pourquoi je te
cite cet exemple là ? Alors, je j'ai
plus fait j'ai fait le recensement
récemment. Combien de ps sont apparus
sur les plateaux télé ? nouveaux experts
stratégiques, tu les retrouves
aujourd'hui sur Poutine. C'est-à-dire
que tu as effectivement, j'ai compté, il
y a une dizaine de psy qui ont été
apparus sur les plateaux télé pour
diagnostiquer Poutine. Alors, il y a
ceux qui disent qu'il est paranout,
d'autres qui disent qu'il est
schizophrène, d'autres qu'il a grossi,
d'autres qu'il a le cancer et cetera et
cetera. Mais personne ne l'a rencontré.
Personne ne l'a rencontré. Donc, tu as
eu deux psychiatres qui ont dit "Non,
nous je suis désolé, on se prête pas ce
genre de jeu, on ne peut pas
diagnostiquer quelqu'un qu'on a jamais
rencontré. L'un d'eux est un psychat
célèbre spécialiste des enfants don le
nombre va me revenir. Mais quand tu as
cette honnêteté intellectuelle
évidemment tu n'apparais pas sur les
plateaux télé. Tu vois pourquoi
j'insiste sur la fabrication de
l'opinion. Donc je sais connais pas
Poutine, j'ai pas de j'ai pas d'opinion
spécialement favorable sur lui mais je
suis pas capable de dire s'il est
schizophrène, paranoïque, cancéreux ou
s'il a fait un régime
ou s'il prend de la cortisone
ou s'il prend de la cortisone à
forcerie.
Donc l'opinion publique,
oui,
les gens comme vous, comme moi,
c'est la clé pour arrêter les conflits.
Absolument, ça, j'en suis absolument
convaincu. On vit dans une société
ouverte. Cette société ouverte, ça veut
dire qu'effectivement toute opinion est
légitime et donc c'est effectivement
quand on n'est pas spécialiste d'une
question, très difficile de se dire
"Mais qui dit la vérité, qui qui est
honnête et cetera."
Mais enfin, c'est le lot de la
citoyenneté, hein. C'est la le lot de
l'esprit civique. C'est-à-dire de se
dire "Ben, si ce sujet m'intéresse, je
vais essayer de lire, je vais essayer de
comprendre, je vais essayer de savoir ce
qui se passe et cetera." Donc tu vois le
il y a aussi des mécanismes que tu peux
mettre à jour. Quand j'ai étudié le
lobby saoudien en France, le lobby
saoudien, enfin plutôt le la comment
dire la communication de l'Arabie
Saoudite, c'était un bouquin que j'avais
appelé comment vendre un pays
invendable. Je me suis aperçu que si tu
veux les Saoudiens euh après le 11
septembre se sont rendus compte que il y
avait quelque chose qui qui allait pas.
Il y a une société américaine de
communication qui s'appelle Corvis qui
est venu voir l'ambassadeur dès le 12
septembre en leur disant "Vous savez,
vous devriez vous préoccuper de votre
communication parce que vraiment vous
vos affaires vont mal."
Et ils ont obtenu un contrat qu'ils ont
centré exclusivement sur la surveillance
du rapport qui était en cours au congrès
parce que tu sais que le Congrès a fait
un rapport sur le 11 septembre. comment
est- ce possible et cetera. Ce Gorvis va
réussir avec l'aide de la Maison Blanche
et un résultat formidable, c'est que il
y a 28 pages du rapport de congrès qui
va être classifié par le président
secret défense. Secret défense donc
incommunicable. Il faudra attendre Obama
14 ans plus tard pour que ces 28 pages
soient soient publiées. Mais pourquoi ?
parce qu'elle concernait le soutien que
l'ambassade saoudienne avait accordé au
groupe de terroristes. Évidemment, le
dire sur le moment, ça voulait dire que
c'était pas l'Afghanistan l'ennemi,
c'était l'Arabie Saoudite. Moi, donc
après ça, ils sont rendus compte
qu'effectivement il fallait commencer à
travailler un peu dans la communication
mais enfin ils étaient forts de l'idée
qu'étant la terre des lieux sains et
cetera et cetera et cetera. Bon, euh
deuxième épisode qui crache, c'est
évidemment Cachogi.
Faire découper un type dans un consulat
à l'étranger, ça fait des ordres. Et tu
remarques que pour Cachogi l'accusation
et en musique
ah ça j'avoue que j'ai pas assisté à ça.
Mais si tu veux si on a si les les Turcs
n'avaient pas sonorisé le consulat tu te
souviens du déroulé de l'opération à
chaque fois que les Saoudiens disaient
non il est sorti regardez il parle et
les autres fournissaient les films en
disant non regardez à l'aéroport c'est
pas lui. Ou alors regardez c'est pas lui
qui monte dans la voiture et cetera et
cetera. Donc ils ont démonté toute la
politique de défense de l'Arabie
Saoudite et ça aboutissait à Mohamed Ben
Salman qui je te le rassure vit
tranquillement sa vie. C'est-à-dire que
tu vois bien qu'il y a des sujets qu'on
ne veut pas aborder. Et pour en terminer
là-dessus, donc les Saoudiens se sont
donc doté de contrat gigantesque avec
les cinq plus grosses boîtes mondiales
de communication, trois américaines et
les deux françaises, publicis et Avas.
Et le plus gros opérateur de lobbying
saoudien à l'étranger, c'est Publicis.
Madame Badinter, une fois interrogée, a
dit "Mais moi, je n'irai jamais en
Arabie Saoudite, donc je ne serai pas
obligé de porter le voile." Bon ben
alors, dans cas, ça va.
Est-ce que tu te trouves partisan ?
Ah bien sûr que je suis partisan. Bien
sûr, je suis le partisan des victimes.
Je suis partisan des victimes.
C'està-dire ceux qui n'arrivent pas à se
faire entendre parce que leur forme de
violence va les condamner
automatiquement si tu veux. Et si je
pense qu'il y a dans leur dans leur
révolte une espèce de légitimité, je
pense que n'étant par exemple ni juif ni
musulman, je peux exprimer quelque chose
si tu veux qu'on ne peut pas
personne n'est parfait. Ah bah oui. Non
mais bien sûr, mais ce que je veux dire,
tu vois l'avantage de n'être pas parti
de l'une des de l'un des deux camps, si
tu veux, évidemment euh on te dit bah
celui-là, il est pas alors des fois, ils
vont t'accuser d'être payé.
Malheureusement, j'arrive pas à me faire
payer. C'est ça qui est très terrible.
Il faut qu'il le sache. Répétons-le.
Répétons-le. Il paye pas. C'est ça.
La Chine.
Alors, la Chine, effectivement, c'est un
sujet intéressant aussi parce que
alors la question que je te pose avant,
c'est purement personnel. Mais est-ce
que tu penses qu'il faut qu'on se
déplace en Chine physiquement ?
Est-ce qu'il faut qu'on aille voir ce
qui se passe en Chine physiquement ?
Il faut bah c'est-à-dire que si tu veux,
tu peux toujours aller voir ce qui se
passe en Chine, mais enfin quand tu sais
que c'est un un pays d'un milliard 200
millions d'habitants, tu peux faire du
radio au trottoir, mais selon que tu le
fais à Pékin dans l'avenue centrale, que
tu le fais dans le Tibet, que tu le fais
au Sinkyang, tu tu le fais dans le
Tu me connais, je fais jamais de radio
trottoir comme ça.
Pardon,
tu me connais, je fais jamais de radio
trottoir comme ça.
Non, mais ce que je veux te dire, tu
vois, c'est que le sujet est tellement
immense. C'est comme la Russie. La
Russie c'est 12 fuseaux horaires quelque
chose comme ça. Donc tu sais bien que tu
vas qui c'est qui me citait ça ? Je
crois que c'était Sapire qui me disait
les gens qui arrivent à Moscou qui font
une journée qui se baladent un peu dans
les rues et qui reviennent faire un
reportage sur la Russie. Il appelé ça le
gang du mariot parce que tout le monde
est au mariot. Bon donc tu vois
encore une fois c'est pas je je mets pas
en question l'honnêteté des gens qui le
font.
Ils sont pauvres.
Pardon ?
Oui mais enfin personne n'est parfait si
tu veux. Mais tu vois, on est sur une
situation où envie
descendre au Mariotte, tu te rends
compte ?
Ah bah oui, mais qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
Peut-être il y avait mieux, mais enfin
il y a quand même, si tu veux, il faut
un minimum de dignité dans le
dans la dépense et puis il y a des notes
de frais tout simplement. Donc euh le
l'idée que tu te retrouves avec à
l'occasion d'une crise une apparition
spontanée d'experts que ces experts
évidemment vont s'exprimer sur les
plateaux télé que sur les plateaux télé
effectivement ils vont dire j'en viens,
j'ai vu, je sais qui sont les gentils,
je sais qu'ils sont les méchants. Et
donc si tu veux, c'est très difficile je
comprends pour un citoyen lambda que de
se dire qu'est-ce que je peux penser sur
tel ou tel sujet. Tu es obligé de
travailler. Tu es obligé de travailler.
Tu as pris la solution.
qu'on avait à d'autres temps. Sur place
et tout. Ça veut dire connaître les
gens, ça
ben ça veut dire lire, ça veut dire
poser des questions, écouter des
émissions. Mais encore une fois, il y a
pas de d'opinion toute faite. Tu peux
pas dire "Oui, oui, ça j'ai bien
compris." Rappelle-toi quand même par
exemple le rôle que jouais Paris Match à
l'époque de la guerre d'Algérie. Tu
avais une espèce de couverture. C'était
l'époque de la photo. Enfinit donc les
gens avaient l'impression de comprendre
ce qui se passait en Algérie, tu vois.
Et donc c'est Cand de Gaul finalement va
commencer à à parler de discuter avec
les avec le le FLN que on va changer si
tu veux et que la légitimité enfin la
reconnaissance de la légitimité
politique de De Gaul va amener
progressivement Paris Match à changer.
Tu avais un grand penseur qui était
Raymond Cartier à Paris Match et Raymond
Cartier était considéré le grand
spécialiste des États-Unis parce qu'il y
allait assez fréquemment. À l'époque,
c'était pas simple d'aller aux
États-Unis, mais tu t'aperçois que ce
mec, il a jamais écrit une ligne sur le
problème noir aux États-Unis.
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ? La
relativité du témoignage.
Plutôt les blancs le problème. Mais bon,
pardon,
c'était plutôt les blancs le problème.
Oui, mais en même temps, tu te dis euh
alors il répercutait, c'est mon père
était à Paris match à l'époque, il
répercutait ce que ce qui s'entendait,
ce qui se disait chez les
chez les Américains, c'estàdire les
noirs sont sales et cetera et cetera.
Ils sont pas éduqués. Enfin, tu connais
le truc, c'était le même que celui des
pieds noirs sur les sur les
sur les Algériens. Euh l'autre fois,
j'ai dit justement à propos du début de
la guerre d'Algérie, j'ai dit
"Rappelez-vous les massacres et cetera."
Or, il a bien fallu un moment de
discuter et je disais notamment la
réaction qui est analogue à celle des
Israéliens aujourd'hui, c'est que les
pieds noirs ont commencé des ratonnades.
J'ai pas je révèle pas un secret défense
mais j'ai quand même reçu un message un
moyage d'injure d'un pied noir qui m'a
dit c'est scandaleux les ratonades c'est
pas tu vois ce je veux dire la
sensibilité même par rapport à des faits
avérés
parce que encore une fois c'était la
réaction de les mois c'était la réaction
de la nécessité de s'armer parce que
n'importe quel arabe pouvait devenir un
terroriste.
Même 50 ans après, tu as encore des mecs
qui disent "C'est pas vrai". Tu vois
quand Gérald Darmanin dit il faut pas
emporter le conflit sur notre territoire
et que le premier truc qu'il fait c'est
que il fracasse Benzema en disant que
c'est que
il fracasse Benzema par tweet interposé
et
oui enfin bon écoutez je t'avoue que
l'opinion de Benzema, je m'en fous.
Non l'opinion de Darmanin, tu t'en fous
aussi ?
Non c'est pas ça. C'est que lui il a une
responsabilité politique. Pourquoi il a
intérêt à assister là-dessus ? que
on peut penser que la l'interprétation
mécanique de ce qui se passe en Gaza
truc peut donner naissance à un
terrorisme importé. Or moi, j'insiste
sur le fait que c'est pas du terrorisme
importé, c'est du terrorisme qui s'est
développé sur le séparatisme, qu'on a
toléré et que donc si tu veux, tu le
vois bien avec des chechen et des
ingouches, c'est pas le fait que c'est
Gaza, ils ont jamais pé, ils savent même
pas localiser Gaza sur une carte. Mais
par contre, le fait qu'on ait laissé
s'installer ce climat sur le thème les
musulmans sont tous massacrés, c'est
scandaleux et cetera fait que tu vas
avoir une espèce de d'émergence
spontanée
euh de gens qui vont tout à coup se
sentir mandatés pour faire un acte de
violence.
Deuxème remarque, encore une fois, le
rôle des des français des Français
musulmans républicains
et comment dire pose un problème grave
parce que j'en discute une fois avec une
amie avec qui je travaillais euh et
comme elle avait un nom un nom arabe et
que moi j'étais n en Algérie, je lui
pose une question. Je lui dis où est-ce
que vous d'où est originaire votre
famille ? Elle me dit si j'avais eu un
nom juif, est-ce que vous m'auriez posé
la question ? Elle m'avait mouché parce
qu'elle me disait à chaque fois que
comme j'ai un nom arabe, à chaque fois
je vais être interpellé quand il y a un
attentat en disant "Bah alors qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez ?" Si elle dit "Mais
je suis français, je sais pas pourquoi
vous me posez la question à moi." Tu
vois ce que je veux dire ? On a donc
vis-à-vis de cette communauté qui elle
ne pose aucun problème républicain
le un espèce de de pas clair si tu veux
parce que on se dit "Bah après tout, on
connaît pas de salafiste, on va
interroger un arabe", tu vois. Et et ça
c'est quand même une situation très
grave. Or, ce sont eux qui sont la
plupart du temps menacés. L'imam de
Bordeaux, Tarekubrou est un type qui vit
sous il a refusé la protection
policière. Il dit "Moi, ma mission c'est
de diffuser le message de paix de
l'islam et cetera. Je veux pas être
défendu par des policiers.
Je veux être défendu par ma communauté.
Je veux être défendu par la force de ma
parole. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est quand même étonnant quoi. Et ce
type, il peut être assassiné demain par
un allumé qui n'aura même pas su qui
savait même pas ce qu'il a raconté dans
ses prêches. Il veut être défendu par la
puissance de sa pensée.
Question internet.
Question à notre ami Pierre Consa. Ayant
en tête les échecs du passé, quelle est
l'issue la plus crédible pour instaurer
la paix entre la Palestine et Israël ?
Quelles institutions doivent participer
à ce processus et quel rôle devrait-elle
avoir ?
Merci beaucoup.
J'ai pas de réponse. J'ai pas de
réponse. J'ai pas de réponse parce que
tu connais ça toi ?
Non non non non non. Je vais pas faire
semblant, moi j'ai la solution et
cetera.
Je te dis malheureusement il y a que le
temps qui peut apporter suffisamment de
sagesse pour se dire on s'est trompé. Je
te dis je te prends l'exemple de la
guerre d'Algérie mais je peux te prendre
l'exemple de n'importe quelle guerre.
Temp
50 ans 100 ans
je sais pas on a eu un espoir avec les
accords de camp David et chacun a été
tué par sa communauté.
Comment tu veux gérer un phénomène comme
ça ? C'est terrible, c'est dramatique.
Tu te dis mais enfin c'est incroyable de
penser que les hommes de paix sont des
hommes qui finalement sont la cible
principale.
Quel regard tu portes sur toutes les
religions et sur tous les dieux ? Est-ce
que c'est
Écoute, moi j'ai écrit un guide du
paradis comme tu le sais. C'est-à-dire
que je me suis dit depuis le temps que
les hommes se foutent sur la gueule pour
expliquer qu'ils ont le Dieu unique et
miséricordieux, on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
match nul. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas de
religion qui l' emporté. Et donc je me
suis dit,
c'est vrai que dans la force de
conviction, il faut quand même se
demander ce qui se passe au paradis
selon qu'on appartient à telle ou telle
entité. Donc finalement, c'est là qu'on
va passer le maximum de temps. Et donc
je me suis dit quelle est l'offre
commerciale du paradis dans les
différentes religions ? Alors tu as des
religions dans lesquelles tu deviens une
espèce de corps évanescent. le
bouddhisme si tu veux, tu sais pas ce
qui t'a problème. Quand tu regardes pour
les catholiques, tu t'aperçois quand tu
regardes les peintures du Moyen-Âge de
la résurrection des morts, les mecs
ressemblent à des endives, ils sont dans
des chasubles blanches. On ne dirait pas
qu'ils vont rigoler. Il y a des anges
qui jouent de la trompette. Tu vois bien
que le paradis musulman est beaucoup
plus attractif parce que quand même, on
te promet,
pour les femmes.
Pardon,
Ah non, non, attends. Non, ne mélange
pas tout. Ne mélange pas tout. Pour les
hommes c'est 24 perpétuellement vierges.
Je sais pas pourquoi ils insistent
toujours sur le fait qu'elles sont
perpétuellement vierges mais
pas 72. Pardon ?
C'est pas 72
peut-être 72, je sais pas. Mes chiffres
sont plus sont plus à jour, j'en sais
rien. Je me suis 72 mais 72 tu les
utilises quand ? Enfin, écoute, faut pas
exagérer quand même.
S'il te plaît, pas de blague.
Non, pas de blague. Et alors, tu te
retrouves dans cette situation
extraordinaire où tu vas avoir euh
des mon postulat c'était de dire "Mais
finalement, c'est au paradis qu'on va
passer le plus de temps." Donc, il vaut
mieux se renseigner avant de partir
parce que si tu t'aperçois que tu es
dans une religion où dans le paradis est
pas spécialement attractif, tu peux
changer mais il faut changer avant de
partir, tu vois. Donc évidemment, ça a
été mal pris ma démonstration mais
pourtant elle est pleine de bon sens.
C'est horrible.
Là, tu as commis un dernier bouquin.
Comment il s'appelle ?
Ben le dernier, c'est du séparatisme au
terrorisme, c'est-à-dire
que j'ai appelé si grave parce que je
trouve que le je trouve que le j'ai
trouvé que si tu veux appréhender la
dangérosité de l'islam radical par le
seul fait des attentats est insuffisant.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'effectivement on
comprend qu'à l'attentat à ce moment-là
il y a des fleurs, des pleurs, des
lamentations, des décisions et cetera,
mais ça veut dire qu'on n pas voulu
mesurer la le processus qui a amené au
terrorisme.
Et moi ce qui me frappait, c'est que
justement il y avait des manifestations
de séparatisme
de plus en plus nombreuses dans de plus
en plus de domaines. C'est-à-dire le les
gosses qui à l'école vont contester
l'enseignement, euh des mecs qui vont se
mettre à faire la prière dans l'aéroport
de Roissie et cetera, des gens qui vont
demander des repas à l'â et cet et donc
on est dans un système où si tu veux se
sont fracturés progressivement un
certain nombre d'adhésions
républicaines.
Al quand même merde, c'est normal.
Attends, attends, attends. Moi je dis,
je répète, la France est le pays qui
accueille la plus grosse communauté
arménienne, la plus grosse communauté
chinoise, la plus grosse communauté
juive et la plus grosse communauté
musulmane des pays de l'Union
européenne. Et nous n'avons des
problèmes qu'avec une partie de la
communauté musulmane. Donc c'est pas
notre système d'intégration qui est en
faillite, c'est la pratique séparatiste
de cette communauté. Donc il faut pas
renverser le la charge de la preuve. Le
système marche mais il y a une partie
qui s'y refuse. Bon donc moi c'est ça
qui m'a intéressé. Et quand tu dis, je
te prends l'exemple à la fois du Téchen
et Lingouche qui arrivent l'un à 2 ans,
l'autre à 5 ans, qui sortent de l'école
républicaine et qui vont aller
assassiner un prof. Donc c'est pas
l'école républicaine qui sont
radicalisés, c'est dans leur famille.
Donc tu vois bien que je t'ai cité
l'exemple de la du droit d'asile. Le
droit d'asile est une énorme trouée
aujourd'hui. On peut pas se permettre
d'accueillir des gens dont on n'est pas
sûr qu'ils adhèrent aux valeurs
républicaines. On peut pas avoir une
espèce de droit d'asile dans lequel
sinon il aurait fallu accorder le droit
d'asile à Hitler en 32.
Bah parce qu'après tout le pauvre, tu
vois, il était condamné. Non mais tu tu
te rends compte le regarde encore une
fois cette cette
situation qu'on a eu avec le Tchenen et
avec la famille Gouche, c'est-à-dire des
gens qui étaient qui ont formé leurs
enfants pour qu'ils deviennent des des
radicaux violents.
Donc il faut un moment si tu veux
recaler nos principes avec la
dangérosité et ça ça veut dire que bah
il faut l'individu a pas spécifiquement
droit à une espèce de droit d'asile.
Et donc on fait quoi ? Ben, d'abord, on
peut réviser les critères d'admission
dans l'asile, hein. Ça c'est une
question importante parce que encore une
fois, si tu mets le mec sur place et
puis alors le problème, tu le connais,
c'est qu'une fois que le mec est ici, si
tu le tu l'expulses pas tout de suite,
après tu l'as sur le ventre et les
procédures d'expulsion sont devenues
extrêmement difficiles.
À un moment, il y avait jusqu'à, je
crois que j'avais calculé, il y avait
jusqu'à 10 procédures judiciaires avant
de pouvoir procéder à une expulsion.
C'est-à-dire, tu avais la première
instance tribunal administratif, le
conseil d'État, le renvoi au tribunal
administratif, ensuite le machin la Cour
de cassation, si les instances
européennes et cetera. C'est-à-dire
qu'au bout d'un certain temps, le type
était là depuis si longtemps que tu
osais plus l'expulser.
Donc tu vois le système se piégeit
lui-même. Deuxième chose,
tu avais effectivement à un certain
moment le
une jurisprudence européenne, je sais
plus de quand elle est, je crois qu'elle
est 2011 ou 2015, peu importe, dans
lesquelles la cour européenne impose que
euh
tu ne puisses pas procéder à une
expulsion d'un individu qui risque
d'être maltraité dans le pays où tu le
renvoies, qui en l'occurrence son pays
d'origine.
Ça veut dire que si tu veux avec cette
jurisprudence, tu te retrouves avec des
mecs qui vont être terroristes,
condamnés, expulsable, inexpulsable
tout le temps.
Attends attends, je te cite le bout le
truc jusqu'au bout. Tu as le cas en
France de gens qui sont terroristes
condamnés par la justice française,
expulsables par la justice française,
inexpulsable par la jusprendance
européenne qui vont être logés, nourris,
blanchis par la République puisque si tu
veux, il faut bien qu'il vivent et qui
vont être mieux traités que des que des
SDF français puisque le SDF, il a droit
au RSA, c'est tout. Donc tu te dis quand
un système aboutit à ce genre
d'abération, il faut quand même de temps
en temps recaler les
T un coup
euh
tu penses qu'on va y arriver ? Quel Quel
est-ce que tu as extrapolé la situation
?
Oui.
Où est-ce que ça ça vous ça nous emmène
tout ça ?
Où est-ce que ça nous emmène en France
Non, je pense qu'on va y arriver si tu
veux. Mais il y aura beaucoup de morts.
Il y aura beaucoup de morts.
Mort comment ?
Ben de morts par attentat, par encore
une fois, je te dis qui pouvait imaginer
que de profs de l'enseignement public
gratuit et républicain allaient être
assassiné.
Donc oui, il va y avoir encore des
morts. Il va y avoir un type qui va se
convaincre que la France est le pays de
la laïcité. C'est l'horreur absolue. Ils
reconnaissent pas les religions. Tu vas
avoir des pratiques comme celle-là. Oui,
bien sûr qu'il va y avoir des morts,
mais tu vois de toucher à la loi sur
l'immigration, faire sauter par exemple
ce verou, tu sais que ce verrou des 13
ans, c'est-à-dire qu'on pouvait pas
expulser un enfant qui arrivait en
France avant 13 ans et qui donc si tu
veux ne pouvait pas être expulsé combien
il pouvait pas être expulsé, la famille
pouvait pas être expulsée et cetera.
Donc voilà, Darmanen va faire sauter ce
genre de verrou mais ça va être dur, ça
va être très dur.
Question internet.
Quel lien entre le financement Qatari,
Netaniau et Amas ? Quel crédit accordé
au document officiel Qatari publié par
le média Blast incluant des noms de
millions d'euros en cash à Netaniaou ?
J'ai je suis pas au courant de ça. Donc
toi
ça je t'avoue alors
les Cataris ont dit qu'il financ.
Ah non non les Qataris de toute façon
c'est sûr que les Qataris ont une place
très originale. Pourquoi les Qataris ?
C'était le petit nain, le nain de du
conseil de coopération du golf hein.
C'était le petit pays à côté des
Émirats, à côté du Kat, à côté de
l'Arabie Saoudite qui était des pays
pétroliers. Et puis en 75, je crois, on
découvre cette gigantesque nape gazière
qui les unit à l'Iran, si tu veux et qui
veulent les faire des gens richissimes.
Bon, le Qatar, c'est une espèce de
presquil si tu veux rattaché à l'Arabie
Saoudite et donc ils vont être assez
intelligents pour mener une politique de
lobbying qui va leur permettre de se
positionner sur un créneau où les autres
ne sont pas.
puisque tu sais ils vont acheter le
Parissing-Germain, ils vont financer le
département des arts islamiques du
Louvre et cetera. Donc ils ont une
politique de lobbying très intelligente
qui fait que finalement tout le monde
sait ce que c'est que le Qatar. Bon le
Paris-Germain marche pas terrible, ils
arrivent pas à gagner une coupe d'Europe
mais enfin quand même. Donc tu vois
cette accroche dans un un lieu social
aussi consensuel que le football,
c'était assez intelligent. Le donc le
Qatar ensuite a développé une diplomatie
qui était une diplomatie d'abord de
conciliation avec l'Iran. Évidemment, il
partage la nave gazière si tu veux. Donc
on se fâche pas avec le le coexploitant
de de sa richesse principale. Et donc
ils sont dans cette situation où ils
vont être considérés par des traites par
l'Arabie Saoudite qui considèrent que la
menace principale c'est l'Iran. Mais par
contre ils savent intelligemment
cultiver leur fonction d'entre gens et
évidemment ils ont ils ont financé le le
Hamas enfin ils ont financé sur Gaza.
Alors quel est-ce que le financement
était directement à ou pas ? Donc ils
utilisent leur argent et de ces
multiples relations, ils se mettent en
position d'intermédiaire, tu le vois
bien aujourd'hui sur la question des
otages où on s'aperçoit que qui peut
parler aujourd' Hamas pour pouvoir
négocier les otages contre autre chose,
la libération des Paralisiens,
tu as pas beaucoup de pays dans le dans
le paysage. Tu as effectivement le
Qatar. Est-ce que c'est eux qui vont
jouer ce rôle d'intermédiaire ? Si tu
veux, c'est un pays qui a vite occupé un
créneau qui était mal géré par les
autres, qui était justement ce pays qui
est à cheval, qui est trop petit pour
inquiéter qui que ce soit et qui peut
valoriser si tu veux son entreg.
De voir un iranien serrer la pogne de
qui déjà dans le golf ? Ils ont serré la
poigne de qui ? On a vu un iranien chez
qui déjà là ?
J'ai pas compris là. Un iranien.
Tu peux voir un iranien ser une poignée
de main à qui déjà là ? Récemment, il y
a on a vu un iranien chez qui c'est pas
compris. Mais c'était sur un plateau
télé.
Non non non, c'était une représentation
officielle.
Il serrait la main à quoi un Israélien ?
Pays un autre pays ? Non, pas un
Israélien. Un saoudien peut-être. Non,
je sais pas. Je sais pas. Je sais pas du
tout. Bon, cela dit, la poignée de main
n'a jamais vexé personne, hein.
Rappelle-toi quand même qu'après les
accords de Munique, on aé on s'est serré
la main, on était content, hein.
Non, je veux dire, faut pas prendre
donner plus de symbolique si tu veux à
des événements.
L'histoire est un référent qu'il faut
continuellement cultiver. Ça c'est pour
tes les gens tu dont tu me disais
comment est-ce qu'on s'informe ? Ouvrir
un livre d'histoire pour essayer de
comprendre comment on est arrivé à cette
situation qui va être le clash absolu,
c'est-à-dire la guerre. Euh, tu peux
essayer de comprendre comment l'autre
fonctionne quoi.
La Chine.
Ouais.
Tu crois qu'on va avoir la guerre avec
la Chine dans pas très longtemps, dans
moins de 3 ans ?
Écoute, la Chine c'est très intéressant
parce que bon, moi il se trouve que j'ai
fait le stage de l'ENAT en Chine mais
c'était en 80, c'est-à-dire on terminait
l'époque de la révolution culturelle.
Tu étais beauvelt,
pardon.
Tu étais beau ette. J'étais beau ette.
Absolument. Et puis surtout si tu veux,
c'était le moment où Tankia commence à
apparaître. il va éliminer la femme de
Maoetong, c'est-à-dire il va solder
complètement le maoïme. Bon et donc il
va construire ce nouveau projet
économique qui est celui de la réussite
formidable de la Chine devenant le
l'espèce d'atelier du monde. Bon donc
la Chine c'est officiellement le péril
jaune. Tu sais que le péril jaune avait
été inventé par Guillaume I parce que il
était en retard à la colonisation et
qu'il se disait merde si je qu'est-ce
qui reste comme espace vide ? resté
quelques espaces en Afrique, mais le
gros morceau c'était la Chine. Donc il
invente le concept de péril jaune
et puis effectivement il dit la Chine
c'est 400 millions d'habitants vous
rendez compte ça va déborder. Bon tu
sais aujourd'hui ils sont 1 million3 ils
sont toujours 1 milliard 3 ils sont
toujours pas débordés mais tu vois
comment se construit le péril jaune.
Alors le système stratégique américain
quand le RSS disparaît manque d' NBI.
C'est un gros problème ça quand même
hein. Donc si tu veux le système
stratégique américain va sortir des
penseurs qui vont devenir les penseurs
universels dont le but principal est de
se dire mais comment garder notre
suprématie sur les autres. Donc il y a
le processus de fabrication de l'ennemi.
Alors les deux auteurs essentiels, tu
les connais, c'est Huntington et et
Fukuyama. Unton va parler du clash des
civilisations en expliquant bien
évidemment que les civilisations
menaçantes, c'est la civilisation
asiatique et la civilisation musulmane.
Bon, on a fait plus d'interventions que
le eux, mais c'est pas grave. C'est eux
qui sont menaçants. Bon, deuxième chose,
effectivement la Chine si tu la compares
à l'Indine, rappelle-toi, l'Indi, c'est
le pays de la non violence. Ils ont fait
une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'interventions extérieures dont des
interventions au Sri Lanka, dont des des
interventions pour détacher le le
Pakistan occidental du Pakistan
oriental. Enfin bref, mais ça fait rien.
L'image est acquise, c'est Gandhi et
cetera. Or, Gandhi est assassiné par un
hindouis radical.
Donc tu vois comment on a du mal à
recaler les images. Donc tu te dis
est-ce que tu juges de la menace d'un
pays par rapport à sa compétence
économique ce qu'on est en train
d'utiliser mais c'est parce qu'on s'est
pas défendu. C'est nous qui avons
inventé le libre échange et inventé la
mondialisation économique. Donc si on
leur imposé d'ailleurs.
Pardon ?
On leur a imposé.
Ah bah oui oui oui bien sûr. Mais ils
ont été ils ont eu l'intelligence de
l'utiliser à leur profit. Bon, mais si
tu veux découvrir aujourd'hui que la
mondialisation, ça ruine nos ouvriers,
ça ruine nos ateliers, euh c'est les
gnomes de Zuric et de de la de la Banque
mondiale qui sont les responsables parce
que ils avaient cette espèce
d'idéologie. Le marché va résoudre tous
les problèmes. C'est pas vrai. Donc, il
faudrait pendre un banquier
international de temps en temps.
Si si si, ça ferait beaucoup de bien.
C'est une blague ?
Ouais, bien sûr.
Comme toujours.
Je les adore les chefs du banquier
internationaux si tu veux. Bien sûr.
Est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec nous que tu as
traité dans ton dernier bouquin ?
Non, je je pense que on a fait un point
en rouge sur la couverture là.
J'ai marqué est si grave.
Attends, laisse laisse mon caméraman
travailler un peu.
Pardon, tu veux quand je regarde comme
ça ?
Alors, descends un peu ta caméra. Tu me
fais le point. Oh, magnifique.
Oubliez pas de vous abonner, activer la
petite cloche et soutenez-nous sur Tipi.
Tu as fait ton point. Tu as fait ton
point. Il y a marqué quoi dessus pour
ceux qui nous écoutent en podcast juste
avant de s'endormir pour passer avec un
petit sujet
bien funky cette nuit de rêve.
Non non mais c'est le titre du livre que
je tu veux que je lise ?
Oui. Et en rouge marqué quoi ? Ça
s'appelle État des lieux du salafhisme
en France, du séparatisme au terrorisme
et j'ai mis en sous-titre est si grave
parce que si tu veux ce qui me frappait
et je voulais que ce soit le titre mais
l'éditeur a refusé parce que tu vois
bien que il y a une espèce de discours
linifiant sur le thème mais finalement
est si grave et cetera. Bon, quand tu es
effectivement avec les attentats de
2015, tu peux quand même te dire "Merde,
ça commence à devenir grave, tu peux le
retrouver en d'autres circonstances et
cetera." Mais tu as une espèce de
comment dire d'habitude dont tu vois euh
si tu reprends le rôle des intellectuels
français dans l'entre de guerre,
c'est-à-dire le moment où si tu veux,
ils sont très dénonciateurs du système
colonial occidental capitaliste et ils
sont complètement aveugles sur ce qui se
passe à l'est.
Donc tu te dis "Mais attends euh on se
rend bien compte qu'on est obligé si tu
veux à un certain moment de sonner une
tirer une sonnette d'alarme.
Rappelle-toi que c'était l'époque où
Sartre était considéré comme le grand
penseur de la France contemporaine.
Or il y a pas un mec qui s'est plus
trompé sur les questions internationales
que lui. Il a été stal, il a été maoïste
et par contre Aaron qui lui était de
droite, il avait ce tort si tu veux
d'être de droite. Donc il pouvait pas
penser juste.
Donc si tu veux, ça devrait permettre si
tu veux de se dire d'abord attention les
intellectuels français sont des j'ai
récemment Vedrine utiliser un terme que
je trouvais très rigolo. Il dit les
intellectuels français Hubert Vedrine
oui Hubert Vedrine utilise un terme que
je trouvais très rigolo. Il disait les
intellectuels français sont des
toutologues, c'est-à-dire c'est des mecs
qui savent tout surtout. Tu vois ce que
je veux dire ? Et c'est une originalité
française. Si tu habites dans le 7e
arrondissement 5e 6e et que tu es du
quartier latin et que tu es parmi ces
intellectuel français labellisé, tu as
le droit de te prononcer surtout. Tu ne
trouves pas ça aux États-Unis parce que
tu as la côte est à la côte ouest parce
que le Middle West est une espèce de
zone si tu veux de comment dire
d'impensé radicale et et tu te dis donc
il faut bien effectivement que notre
système il a son originalité. son
originalité, c'est ça et c'est contre ça
que j'ai essayé de que j'ai essayé de
d'auditer. Mais j'en fais partie, hein.
Je suis pas je fais partie de cette
catégorie, non pas de toutologue parce
que j'essaie de démontrer que je ne sais
pas certaines choses, mais c'est surtout
l'idée que tu vois ma voix d'expert
ma voix d'expert est prise par moment
comme si c'était une vérité.
Question internet, question à notre
invité. Au vu du niveau stratosphérique
de nos élites actuelles, des crises à
venir et de la sociopathisation de notre
société, le risque de guerre civile
est-il probable dans un pays aussi
développé que le nôtre ?
Tu veux que je répète la question ?
Non non non, je comprends la question.
Le terme de guerre civile est très fort
parce que ça voudrait dire si tu veux
qu'on connaisse quelque chose qui est
véritablement
de camps qui peuvent se faire la guerre.
enfin des massacres et cetera. Bon, il y
a un phénomène de guerre civile, ça il
faut le reconnaître, mais simplement il
est sous forme d'attentat terroriste, ce
qui est pas vraiment une guerre civile.
C'est-à-dire que si on fait ce bilan
encore une fois de de la somme des
attentats qui sont passés sur le
territoire français, euh le regarde par
exemple ce qui est fantastique à
l'occasion de la manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme. Tout le débat politique
c'est concerné à concerné la
participation ou pas du rassemblement
national.
problématique formidable. Simplement,
moi j'ai tendance à penser que le
danger, c'est pas l'antisémitisme, c'est
l'islamisme radical. Or, personne n'a
parlé de l'islamisme radical parce que
aujourd'hui l'antisémitisme français, ça
n'est plus un antisémitisme d'extrême
droite. C'est un antisémitisme d'origine
musulmane qui effectivement pour qui
fait que tu vas te retrouver partout
avec des tags sur des maisons et cetera
et cetera. Tu vois bien que c'est une
manifestation multiple et donc elle a
une origine qui est origine musulmane
islamiste évidemment et non pas
l'extrême rot quoi.
Est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec nous au bout
de ce fait quoi 1h50 qu'on est ensemble
1h51 ? Est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder et je laisse 3 4
minutes en plus à notre communauté pour
nous poser les questions ? Non, moi j'ai
pas de Non, non, je crois que j'ai parlé
librement en essayant de répondre à tes
questions, en essayant d'ouvrir sur
d'autres choses. Non, j'ai pas de
Comment tu juge la couverture médiatique
du conflit ? Est-ce que tu as suivi la
presse internationale ? Est-ce que tu
Moi, je trouve que ce conflit Gaza
Israël, si tu veux, a été étonnant par
certaines des fractures qui se sont
déclarées dans cette des sociétés.
Regarde sur les universités américaines
où tu avais traditionnellement quand
même un soutien assez inconditionnel à
Israël, tu t'aperçois qu'il y a eu des
manifestation proalestinienne et cetera
et cetera. Tu vois la même chose ici en
France, tu des gens qui vont refuser de
participer à la manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme en prétendant qu'en fait
eux ils sont solidaires des
palestiniens. Mais ça n'a rien à voir.
Tu peux condamner l'antisémitisme et
soutenir les Palestiniens. Mais tu vois
combien le jeu se réduit à une espèce de
débat politicien français qui me fait
désespérer de la qualité intellectuelle
des des hommes politiques français. Donc
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ?
Quand tu vois au qued d'Orsa que il y a
certains diplomates qui écrivent des
lettres, qui écrivent des machins qui
disent voilà avant c'était pas comme ça
mais et puis maintenant la France elle a
une politique qui est peut-être pas
bonne.
C'est quoi ?
Écoute moi j'ai pas lu le texte
justement tu démissionnes dans
je suppose que c'est ce texte des
diplomates sur le réorientation de la
politique moyen-orientale de de Macron.
écris des textes ou tu démissionnes et
ensuite tu écris
bah théoriquement tu démissionnes. Oui,
bien sûr, mais enfin la soupe est bonne,
hein, quand même. Donc, tu démissionnes
pas quand tu es diplomate, quoi.
C'est quoi la soupe est bonne ?
Bah, tu sais quand tu l'originalité du
système français, c'est que quand tu es
en poste, tu multiplies ton salaire par
deux, trois enfin ou quatre, ça dépend
des postes. Enfin, il y a des taux
d'application. Dans le système anglais
ou système américain, tu as le même
salaire qu'en métropole, mais tu as la
voiture et l'appartement payé. Ça veut
dire que le décalage entre le poste et
le la métropole est beaucoup moins fort
que dans le système français. Au d'Orsc,
ce sont les primes quand tu compares les
primes des ministères, c'est c'est un
des ministères dans lesquels les primes
parisiennes sont très faibles. Bon, donc
tu te dis quand je dis la soupe est
bonne, je dis tu renonces pas à un
statut de diplomate.
Tu as les études des enfants à payer, tu
as des tas de choses à faire comme ça
quoi.
D'autres choses ?
Non, non, non. Je sais pas si je vais
être assassiné à la sortie d'ici, mais
enfin ne donne pas l'adresse quoi.
Tu as eu un jour demander une protection
policière ?
Non non, je suis allé à un moment
déposer plainte parce que euh dans ces
prises de position où je critiquais
Netaniaahou, j'ai eu des sur internet
des mecs qui m'ont dit "Si je te crois,
je te crache à la gueule, je te verra,
je te casse la gueule." Enfin, des
choses comme ça. Bon, donc je suis allé
les signaler au commissariat parce que
je me suis dit on sait jamais ce qui va
se passer mais ça n'a pas pris la forme
de par exemple, tu sais, il y a un site
qui est votre réputation sur internet.
Tu sais, j'ai pas de critique sur
internet. Donc, je me dis je dois être
comme Saint-Pierre, je marche sur les
eaux.
Qui a eu une Tu connais la suite ? Non,
c'est pas
non. Quoi ? Non,
rien.
Tu veux dire, on a trouvé le truc
comment il a fait Jésus pour marcher sur
l'eau ? Non, pas encore.
Question internet une dernière.
Alors, un avis sur l'ingérence russe qui
qui aurait payé des agents pour taguer
les étoiles de la David et jeter de
l'huile sur le feu.
Je sais pas. Tu sais pas. Oui, il y a
une histoire il y a une histoire de
milliardaire Moldave qui raconte qu'en
fait c'était pour rendre service au à la
communauté juive. Je sais pas. Je sais
pas. Toute façon non, faut pas se cacher
derrière son petit doigt. Il y a un
antisémitisme qui effectivement est un
antisémitisme qui a des sources
musulmanes, islamistes, radicales,
salafistes, qui est celui-là qui est le
véritable danger aujourd'hui sur la
communauté juive. C'est pas le l'extrême
droite, on va pas voir Marine Le Pen
aller massacrer du juif. Donc tu vois
combien ce décalage est fort aujourd'hui
entre une espèce de communauté politique
qui vit sur elle-même et qui refuse de
désigner quel est le risque principal.
Question internet, un commentaire sur le
voyage de Macron en Asie centrale entre
parenthèses Mongolie, Kazakhstan,
Uzbekistan. Point d'interrogation.
Non, je sais pas, j'ai pas de
chercher un peu de d'uranium.
On va chercher un peu d'uranium.
Peut-être après tout, mais c'est sa
fonction. Je veux dire, on a une filière
nucléaire, il faut garantir ses
approvisionnements. Le Mali et le Niger
qui étaient nos fournisseurs habituels
risquent de déstabiliser. Moi qui se
prennent un coup d'avance, pourquoi pas
? Est-ce que le degré de performance des
différents ministères euh clé, c'est la
balance commerciale française ?
Non, c'est
Est-ce qu'on peut mesurer l'efficacité
de nos politiques, l'efficacité de nos
renseignements, l'efficacité de nos
diplomatie
à l'évolution de la la balance
commerciale ?
Non, je crois pas. D'abord parce que la
balance commerciale c'est une chose. Le
cours de la balance d'échange si tu veux
c'est autre chose. C'est-à-dire tu peux
avoir une balance d'échange positif avec
une balance commerciale déficitaire
parce que dans l'échange tu as les
services, tu as le les flux financiers
et cetera. Bon donc le fait de la
balance commerciale n'est qu'un des
indicateurs. Si nos entreprises sont pas
compétitifs, c'est pas la faute des
diplomates. En tout cas, moi j'ai pas
tendance à le penser comme ça. Donc soit
effectivement
juste un détail si on se fait boouter
par les Américains du marché automobile
iranien et que derrière eux ils vont
s'implanter, comment ça se passe ?
Ah bah écoute, comment ça se passe ?
Non non mais je sais pas, je sais pas.
Toute façon
quand on se fait liquider à stom ou
quand on se fait saisir à stom ou quand
on vend ou quand on
qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Une fois, on est dans une guerre
commerciale, c'est-à-dire tu vas pas
reprocher aux diplomates de pas suivre
le la négociation sur Alsom. C'est le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
qui devait sealerter, qui devait agir,
qui devait faire ce qu'il fallait.
Les services de renseignement français,
ils sont censés protéger. Non,
mais tu fais pas avec des agents de
renseignement qui sont principalement
d'origine civile et militaire des
spécialistes du monde financier et
industriel.
Attends, mais on n plus à ta génération
maintenant Pierre.
Mais comment on n plus à ma génération ?
Qu'est-ce que tu crois comme génération
?
Pardon. dans ta génération, peut-être
queil y avait dû laisser aller de la
nonchalance en question guerre
économique, mais maintenant on est au
21e siècle. Est-ce que
Mais ce n'est pas la fonction des
services de renseignement parce que tu
n'as pas des
Pourqui c'est pas Non mais il faut
arrêter les les conneries là.
Pardon pardon.
Pourquoi c'est pas la fonction des
services de renseignement ?
Mais parce que tu ne fais pas un
spécialiste financier avec un mec qui
n'a pas fait ce métier là. C'est-à-dire
que tu à ce moment attends attends, tu
dois Non, non, mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut avoir la modestie de penser que le
travail de renseignement a complètement
changé. Si on a inventé l'intelligence
économique, c'est justement parce que
c'est un métier en soi. Et ce métier en
soi, si on a pensé à le structurer
autour d'un ancien du renseignement qui
est juillet, c'est parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'effectivement ce n'était
pas la fonction des services de
renseignement qui évidemment ont
vocation à se préoccuper de la menace
surtout militaire, de la menace
terroriste et cetera. Mais encore une
fois, tu fais pas un spécialiste du
renseignement militaire ou ou
terroriste, un spécialiste des questions
financières. Donc je te dis l'existence
même de l'intelligence économique montre
que c'est un métier.
Question internet : quelle serait sa
vision idéale de l'avenir et des très
grandes lignes pour le monde en général
? Quel système fiable et cetera ? Quelle
politique ?
C'est tout ?
Ouais, si tu veux, je je t'accorde 10
minutes, une minute de plateau télé si
tu veux. Vas-y, fais-toi plaisir.
Non, non, mais tu vois, c'est une
question, j'ai pas de monde idéal
malheureusement. Si j'avais la solution,
je n'hésiterai pas
à la diffuser. Non non, c'est
malheureusement
le les sociétés sont composées d'hommes,
d'êtres humains avec leur travers, leur
intelligence, leur capacité. La même
société est capable de produire l'abé
pierre et puis
un assassin
tu vois d'un professeur. Donc qu'est-ce
que tu veux que je te dise ? J'ai pas de
solution.
Question internet. Que pense monsieur
Conissa de la théorie de Naomi Klin la
stratégie du choc, comment les crises
politiques et économiques ont été
exploitées pour imposer des politiques
néolibérales et des changements
structurels par des acteurs politiques
et économiques influents ?
Écoute, c'est une question difficile
encore une fois parce que moi je suis
pas vraiment un spécialiste des
questions économiques et financières,
mais la question est légitime,
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement
le néolibéralisme s'est imposé comme
l'espèce de modèle paradisiaque sur
lequel le monde allait lisser toutes ces
conflits que les conflits
n'apparaîtraient plus si s'il y avait
des coopérations économiques et cetera
et cetera.
ce modèle néolibéral, on envoie les
résultats aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement, tu vas avoir de la
perte de substance parce que des pays
moins 10 ans vont gagner des emplois ou
vont gagner des savoir-faires et des
pays au contraire où les protections
sociales sont importantes vont perdre du
travail. Donc si tu veux, ce modèle
néolibéral était le modèle de l'école de
Chicago, c'est-à-dire des mecs qui ont
dit "Non, non, nous on a trouvé la
solution. Regarde, ils ont appliqué la
thérapie de choc au au Chili après
Aliend. Ça a été une catastrophe. Mais
ce que je sache, il y en a aucun qui
s'est tiré une balle dans la tête, hein.
Donc tu vois cette cette espèce de de
croyance que tu sais, moi il y a un
sujet que je j'ai un un exemple que je
cite souvent, mais dans le système
français, si tu fais classe prépa
normal sup science poat,
grand corps, cabinet, tu t'aperçois que
pendant 10 ans, tu n'as pas touché
terre. Tu n'as fait que de la théorie.
Tu connais pas le pays dans lequel tu
vis et tu à forcerie, tu connais pas le
monde. Donc si tu veux, moi j'avais dit
une fois, j'ai dit à Vedrine mais vous
devrez imposer une année sabbatique à
tous les mecs qui sortent des grandes
écoles qui fassent des ONG de
l'humanitaire tra qui traversent la
planète, j'en sais rien, mais que tout à
coup ils redescendent sur terre. Or, tu
t'aperçois que non. Si tu peux trouver
le poste de cabinet tout de suite, tu
vas avoir une trajectoire de météorite,
tu veux et puis évidemment après tu vas
décider de l'avenir du monde. Donc
l'école de Chicago, je pense que c'est à
peu près ça. Les mecs raisonnaient sur
des modèles théoriques et puis ils ont
fait cette catastrophe au Chili qui a
été une crise sociale dramatique quoi.
Dernière question internet. Le colonel
Chervinski serait aurait dirigé l'équipe
qui a fait exploser en septembre 2022
les deux pipelanes en mer Baltique selon
une enquête conjointe du Spigle et du
Washington Post. La question c'est on
fait quoi maintenant ?
Je sais pas, je sais pas. Moi je suis
pas encore une fois d'abord je prétends
pas être un homme du renseignement donc
je sais pas des fois je lis des trucs
dans les journaux mais je n'ai aucun
moyen de savoir si c'est vrai ou si
c'est pas vrai. Je te dis la
manipulation de l'opinion fait partie de
la guerre moderne. La manipulation de
l'opinion. Donc si tu peux avoir faire
passer dans un journal respecté comme le
spigle telle ou telle information dont
j'ai que je n'ai aucun moyen de vérifier
si tu veux. Mais tu vois bien que moi je
vais pas me prononcer là-dessus, j'en
sais strictement rien.
Selon des sources bien informées, on
dirait que Jésus aurait marché sur les
eaux. Tu vois,
tu l'as pas vu toi ? Non, tu étais pas
là.
Non, justement mais tu vois, il y a
plein de gens qui croient.
Et tu as essayé de le faire depuis ?
Bah,
je t'imagine bien en toge.
En en quoi ?
En toge. Marcher sur les eaux.
Ah, tu crois qu'il faut une toge pour
marcher sur ? Je sais pas. Donc si tu
veux, tu vois bien que toutes les
religions sont quand même la preuve que
si tu veux la croyance de la comment
dire le
l'importance de la de l'adhésion si tu
veux à une idéologie est extrêmement
importante. Tu sais il y a fascine une
chose qui me fascine mais qui a
strictement rien à voir avec le ce dont
on parle la mode des pantalons déchirés.
Tu te dis comment est-ce qui est arrivé
cette mode ? Alors, je me posais une
question idiote. Je me disais "Est-ce
qu'un pantalon plus déchiré vaut plus
cher qu'un pantalon moins déchiré ?"
J'ai pas réussi à trouver de réponse.
C'est parce que tu vas pas faire les
boutiques avec tes enfants.
Pardon ?
Tu vas pas faire les boutiques avec tes
enfants.
Oui, mais encore une fois, comment c'est
popularisé ? C'est tu veux d'avoir
l'idée d'avoir un pantalon déchiré ? Tu
vois, pour moi, c'est exactement le
contraire de tout ce que j'ai vécu toute
ma vie. Mais ça a quelque chose de
fascinant. Ça veut dire qu'un effet de
mode et je le prends volontairement sur
un sujet aussi futile que la question du
pantalon, ça te prouve que les capacités
de conviction
sont fascinantes. Regarde le cas
d'Hitler, un mec un petit brun avec une
petite moustache qui devenait l'idole
des grands blancs aux yeux bleus.
Est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Ben, d'abord le mien.
Non, ça c'est interdit.
Ah bon ? Ça c'est interdit. Bon, vas-y,
lis-moi le la lis-moi une page. Tu tes
lunettes.
Mais une page,
un début de page voir un truc
intéressant quand même hein.
Alors,
ce livre est dédié aux français
musulmans. Non,
non, non. Tu t'imagines en train de me
lire la page, imagine-toi, je suis
tranquille et je veux un ton de voix.
Genre, tu veux pas faire tes bouquins en
audiobook ?
Tu veux pas quoi ?
Faire tes livres en audiobook. Bah si
c'est possible, oui, mais enfin tu sais
qu'en ce moment, je suis en train de
faire un documentaire et justement sur
le complexe militaire intellectuel et on
m'oblige à faire la voix off. Bah, il
intérêt
attends attends attends attends mais je
me rends compte si tu veux combien c'est
difficile. C'est-à-dire la fille qui me
qui m'a pris en tutelle me fait répéter
12 fois 15 fois en disant non c'est trop
lisse. C'est un prof qui parle, c'est
pas un commentaire. Tu te dis mais
attendez, je parle normal. Non,
fais-moi la lecture. Imagine-toi que je
suis en train de caresser mon chat là.
Alors,
nombre de sites internet dressent des
recensements des
Tu fais fuire le chat là,
pardon.
Tu fais fuir le chat.
Bon ben alors, je te le lis pas si tu
veux si tu veux regarder les images, je
peux te le passer mais il y en a pas.
Non, écoute
un petit bout, un petit bout, un petit
bout.
Oui, mais si tu veux, je vais te lire un
truc. Si ça a son rapport avec le reste,
je vais te lire la dédicace.
Mantra à répété plusieurs fois par jour
par toute personne intéressée par le
sujet. En un seul mot, ne pas
stigmatiser, ne pas amalgamer, cela n'a
rien à voir avec l'islam. Les choses ne
sont pas si simples. Faut le dire en une
fois hein, faut pas s'interrompre.
Comment il s'appelle son livre ?
Il s'appelle est si grave. Est-ce que tu
as deux autres bouquins à nous à nous
Alors non non le mien on le laisse de
côté bien évidemment mais écoute donc
comme je travaille en ce moment sur
cette histoire de victimisation et de
repentance, je suis en train de lire un
bouquin, je crois de Bruckner qui
s'appelle la tyrannie de la pénitence.
Euh qu'est-ce que j'ai d'autre en ce
moment ?
Tu pourrais me préparer quand même avant
que j'arrive.
Ça fait combien de temps que tu viens
ici ?
Ben oui, mais je vais pas me faire à
chaque fois je vais réviser mes mes
expériences passées. Non. Euh il y a un
bouquin sur les
comment est-ce qu'il s'appelle celui-là
? Nom de Dieu de nom de Dieu. Euh
jure pas ici. Attention.
Bah si si parce que moi je suis je suis
bien avec tout le monde si tu veux avec
tous les dieux. Ils savent que j'ai tout
valorisé dans le guide du paradis donc
je suis absolument garanti. Le problème
encore une fois ça va être de savoir
dans quel paradis j'irai. Donc je vais
peut-être me convertir à l'islam vers la
fin si tu veux pour être sûr que les 72
vierges ça marche. Bon donc je sais pas.
Écoute, il faudrait que j'y réfléchisse.
Alors, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Pardon ?
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations
ou un film avant. Tu as pas un film à
nous conseiller ? Tu
sais ce que j'ai vu récemment de très
intéressant sur le
tu sais, je sais je sais plus
finalement.
Alors, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Bah, le conseil pour les jeunes
générations, si tu veux, c'est que
moi, j'ai vécu mes 68.
Pourquoi je prends cet exemple là ?
Parce que on était à l'époque la
génération du babyibou, tu sais, de
l'après-gerre et donc le monde devait
changer. Ce monde que nous laissait nos
ancêtres étaient vraiment stupides. Bon,
on virait dans une connerie absolument
délirante, hein. C'est absolument
extraordinaire. C'est-à-dire que si tu
veux, on était un mélange de maoïsme et
d'anarchisme et cetera et donc ce vieux
monde devait disparaître.
Comme disait l'autre, quand j'avais 20
ans, j'avais voulu que tout explose.
Quand j'avais 30, j'avais commencé à
m'inquiéter. Quand j'en ai eu 60, je
j'ai eu peur que tout explose. Bon,
c'est un processus normal. Quand tu es
jeune, tu crois que ce monde peut être
modifié par toi. C'est vrai qu'il peut
l'être, mais c'est vrai qu'il peut
l'être sans faire du passé table race,
comme disait le l'international. Parce
que effectivement les gens qui ont
précédé, notamment les parents de ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui en poste sont des
gens qui ont qui ont essayé de bien
faire. Est-ce qu'ils y ont réussi ?
Est-ce qu'ils ont pas réussi ? Ça, j'en
sais strictement rien. On ne peut
toujours penser qu'on a pas assez fait.
On a évité la guerre,
on a réussi la réconciliation
franco-allemande. On s'était tapé trois
fois sur la figure. On était on sortait
en 45 d'un pays ravagé. L'Allemagne
était aussi rasée, l'Europe était en
ruine. Et vous avez deux hommes d'état
qui sont de Gol et Adenower qui
décident, on arrête le match. Tu sais
quand de Gol a invité Adenuer, il a
invité à colomber les deux églises parce
que il avait trop peur que s'il invitait
à Paris des manifestations contre l'idée
du traité de l'Élysée. Mais évidemment,
il faut des hommes d'état dans RAR,
c'est-à-dire des gens qui d'abord de
Gaul, on connaît son histoire, mais
Adener avait fait la guerre dans l'armée
danoise ou dans l'armée norvégienne, je
sais plus. Donc si tu veux, c'était des
gens qui n'avaient pas ce passif et qui
pouvaient effectivement imaginer quelque
chose qui était totalement inimaginable.
Bon euh tu sais euh le homme d'État, tu
le reconnais souvent à postérieur. Moi
chevainement m'a envoyé son bouquin de
mémoire quand il est il est parti. Je
lui envoyé un moi en disant "C'est
marrant comment on découvre une la
dimension d'un homme d'état quand il
prend sa retraite.
Voilà, tu en as quelques-uns comme ça.
Lui, il a pas hésité à poser sa
casquette quand il était pas d'accord.
Euh tu peux les compter sur les doigts
d'une seule main. Les gens qui
considèrent que leurs idées, il faut les
défendre jusqu'au bout. Voilà. Donc faut
aller chercher pardon.
C'est ça ton conseil ?
Ouais. Ouais. Mon conseil que surtout ne
faites pas du passé table rase. Essayez
de voir effectivement comment le passé
peut être amélioré. On peut pas aller
dans un processus révolutionnaire. On n
plus la trip la trip pour ça. Et
d'ailleurs, on n'est pas une population
assez jeune pour faire la révolution.
Moi, j'ai pensé que je pouvais faire la
révolution si tu veux, mais bon, je me
dis que j'étais un peu prétentieux quand
même.
Pierre connaît ça. Merci
de rien. Merci à toi.
[Musique]